[Applaudissements]
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à madame laurence trastour
isnard monsieur le premier ministre nous
sommes face à une vérité un véritable
scandale d'état
les travaux exemplaires et courageux
dévoilés ce matin par la commission d'
enquête relative à la lutte contre la
fraude aux prestations sociales présidée
par mon collègue patrick hetzel révèle
une réalité intolérable oui monsieur le
premier ministre
la fraude aux aides sociales atteint des
montants qui donnent le vertige et qui
exige une réponse extrêmement ferme du
gouvernement
pourtant vous continuez d'être dans le
déni 1,8 millions 1,8 million c'est le
chiffre des cartes vitale illicites qui
ouvre frauduleusement des droits
pourtant le ministère des solidarités de
la santé assuré il ya quelques jours
qu'il n'en restait qu'un peu plus de
cent cinquante mille le nombre de
personnes pouvant bénéficier de
prestations sociales est supérieur au
nombre total de la population française
le nombre de numéros de sécurité sociale
répertoriant trop serait au minimum de
2,4 au maximum de 6,7 millions vous fait
perdurer un flou artistique sur la
question plusieurs milliers voire
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
seraient volés chaque année aux
contribuables par la fraude aux
prestations sociales
nous faisons face à un pillage
systématique et massif de notre système
de santé et de solidarité
cette gabegie ne peut plus être un sujet
tabou
il faut sanctionner les fraudeurs votre
gouvernement doit cesser de nier la
réalité
or vous fait tout le contraire puisque
nous apprenons que monsieur vers ont
envoyé une lettre de mission de quatre
pages au directeur de la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie
sans que jamais
jamais le mot fraude ne soit cité une
seule fois
alors monsieur le premier ministre au
delà des mots la lutte contre la fraude
sociale est elle réellement une priorité
de votre gouvernement
merci j'ai pris la parole qu'à monsieur
olivier du soap ministre chargé des
comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
vous avez évoqué les travaux menés par
la commission d enquête présidée par le
député patrick hetzel vous auriez pu
aussi citer les travaux de la cour des
comptes missionné par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat qui a rendu
son rapport le 8 septembre dernier
ces rapports ont pas certains aspects
des propositions qui sont utiles des
constats qui peuvent être instructif
dans la matière quand on parle de fraude
sociale que l'on parle de fraudes aux
prestations mais aussi de fraude aux
cotisations sociales
il faut en permanence je crois veiller
aux mots que l'on utilise ne pas nourrir
polémique ne pas avoir deux discours qui
soit caricatural et encore moins s'était
jeté le problème propre sur celles et
ceux qui campent qui en bénéficient
légitimement les rapports vous avez
cités ont aussi un autre mérite c'est
qu'il faut un certain nombre de constats
le constate depuis 2010 le nombre de cas
de fraudes détectées a été multiplié par
trois le constat qu un nom
le nombre de cas a augmenté de 2 kg de
cas détectés a augmenté de 10%
et il souligne aussi que les caisses de
sécurité sociale consacrent plus de 4000
équivalents temps plein à la lutte
contre la fraude
nous déployons des outils de lutte
contre la fraude nous le faisons en nous
appuyons par exemple sur les
recommandations faites par carole
granjon en matière de lutte contre le
les cartes vitale surnuméraires et ce
nombre baisse de manière extrêmement
importante
nous coordonnons les services de
renseignement et service enquête nous
avons créé une mission
interministérielle à dessein le 15
juillet dernier
nous mettons en oeuvre tous les moyens
pour améliorer le recouvrement
parce que c'est une chose de notifier
des sanctions c'est une autre chose que
de pouvoir recouvrer les sommes qui sont
dues par ceux qui ont fraudé et nous
ouvrons des batailles contre la fraude
dans de nouveaux champs
je pense notamment cette année à la
question de l'activité partielle pas
plus tard qu'hier avec madame la
ministre du travail nous mettions en
place de nouveaux dispositifs
le gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
madame il est
au delà de la dureté du ton vous avez
voulu employer qui je le répète n'est
pas forcément important merci monsieur
le ministre la parole la parole à
monsieur le président christophe
castaner merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs monsieur le premier ministre
les français sont inquiets ils sont
inquiets face à la crise de lakovic 19
ils sont 1 créée parce que personne ici
ne doit oublier que le virus septembre
n'est pas moins puissant moins dangereux
que le virus du mois d'avril du mois de
mars pour lequel nous avons été
totalement mobilisés le combat est bien
sûr celui de la responsabilité
individuelle de chacun par nos gestes
par nos comportements nous devons
veiller à lutter contre la copie de 19
mais évidemment je sais combien les
services de l'état et en particulier de
la santé je sais combien le gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre est
totalement mobilisée dans ce combat là
mais aujourd'hui les français sont
inquiets les français sont inquiets pour
l'avenir de l'économie des français sont
inquiets pour leur souveraineté
économique les français sont inquiets
pour la reconquête nationale que nous
devons construire et je sais monsieur le
premier combien ils attendent du plan de
relance dans cette stratégie de
reconquête nationale
le plan de relance et un effort pour la
solidarité engagé depuis le début de la
crise vis-à-vis des français le plan de
relance c'est un impératif pour
construire une france plus forte plus
respectueuses du climat plus forte aussi
dans l'accompagnement de la transition
énergétique
le plan de relance est aussi une façon
de rendre notre pays plus compétitif
plus attractif le plan de relance enfin
monsieur le premier ministre doit se
construire au plus près des habitants
ma question monsieur le premier ministre
est de savoir comment au quotidien
nous allons pouvoir accompagner chaque
territoire chaque habitant pour faire en
sorte que ce dernier qui l'homme
être opérationnel de la reconquête
nationale que nous construisons depuis
2017 soit opérationnel est au service de
tous les français
merci merci monsieur le président la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président monsieur
le président christophe castanet d'abord
prêté permettez moi de vous féliciter de
votre élection à la tête du groupe
majoritaire
au terme d'un débat riche et fructueux
qui est à mettre à l'honneur de ce
groupe
vous m'interrogez mesdames et messieurs
les députés vous m'interrogez un moment
très particulier de notre histoire où la
crise sanitaire n'est pas terminée et où
la crise économique et sociale
s'installe cette simple constatation
dont vous savez qu'elle n'est pas propre
à la france qu'elle concerne l'europe et
le monde devrait collectivement nous
inciter à la sérénité à l'humilité est à
la recherche de solutions constructives
c'est en tout cas la voie que poursuit
le gouvernement
c'est en tout cas le principal objectif
monsieur le président du plan de relance
que nous avons récemment annoncé
je voudrais remercier tous les groupes
sur tous les bancs ici réunis pour les
contributions qu'ils ont bien voulu
apporter dans le cadre de la
concertation que nous avons conduite
avant la divulgation de ce plan sachez
sachez que certaines ont été
particulièrement utile dans le cadre de
ce travail conduit sous la
responsabilité de bruno le maire
ministre chargé de la relance que je
remercie publiquement
ici vous avez rappelé monsieur le
président que ce plan s'inscrit dans la
continuité de l'action gouvernementale
pour faire face aux conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
sanitaire et surtout les banques surtout
les banques vous devriez reconnaître que
les mesures prises par mon prédécesseur
puis par moi même débattu et voté dans
cet hémicycle ont été parmi les plus
ambitieuses d'europe qu'est le zoo
sauver notre économie que le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens a été celui
qui a été le plus préservé
c'est la vérité c'est la vérité et le
plan de relance de 100 milliards dont il
est maintenant question s'est inscrit
dans le droit fil des 470 milliards et
des actions que nous avons déjà
entreprises
c'est un autre honneur collectif c'est à
l'honneur de la france je le répète
je vous rappelle aussi à toutes et à
tous que un certain nombre des
dispositions de ce plan et vous les avez
voté sont d'ores et déjà entrée en
vigueur
il s'agit en particulier des mesures ô
combien urgentes destinées à l'emploi et
à la formation des plus jeunes qui j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le rappeler ici se
présente particulièrement nombreux en
cette rentrée scolaire sur un marché du
travail particulièrement déprimées nous
avons mis le paquet deuxièmement les
mesures consacré à l'industrie sont
également entrées en vigueur depuis
quelques semaines la logique de ce plan
l'auteur de la question l'a rappelé elle
est très claire il s'agit de contribuer
à faire face aux conséquences immédiates
de la crise c'est le premier objectif
relancer par l'investissement et par la
consommation
les carnets de commandes des entreprises
éviter la déprime de l'activité
conséquence de la crise sanitaire éviter
les licenciements par tous moyens et
préférer l'activité partielle au renvoi
des salariés les moyennes déployés à ce
titre monsieur le président sont inédit
dans l'histoire des luttes contre la
crise
inciter à laon gauche les entreprises
qui n'auraient pas tendance
naturellement à recruter
compte tenu de la conjoncture mais ce
plan et c'est sa force et son
originalité continue aussi à préparer la
france au monde d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
ce n'est pas qu'un plan conjoncturel
c'est un plan structurel
beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont suggéré dans
leur contribution il favorise d'abord la
transition écologique de notre pays
le fret l'hydrogène la filière bois
l'isolation thermique
il y en a pour 35 milliards d'euros
la souveraineté économique l'industrie
je les ai évoqué les efforts que nous
avons déployés pour l'aéronautique pour
l'industrie automobile et qui ont été
déjà couronnée de succès l'agriculture
et les filières la recherche avec par
ailleurs la loi de programmation que
vous allez être conduit à examiner
c'est un plan pour tous les français
mesdames et messieurs les députés tous
les français les jeunes je les dis n'est
plus démunis les plus démunis et nous
prolongerons cet effort dans le cadre de
la loi de finances pour 2021 que vous
allez examiner la santé de nos
concitoyens avec la mise en place du
ségur les réorganisation et la
modernisation de notre système de soins
les transports au quotidien qui seront
financés par le plan de relance c'est un
plan pour tous les territoires sujets
sur lesquels vous avez à plusieurs
reprises appelé notre attention
on va finir de déployer le très haut
débit
les petites villes de demain les coeurs
de villes partout dans le monde rural
bénéficieront de crédits du plan de
relance comme les quartiers pour la
politique de la ville nous allons
régénérer des petites voies de chemin de
fer laissé à l'abandon depuis des années
grâce au plan de relance
et oui et oui et pardonnez moi monsieur
le député castaner de ne pas être
exhaustif mais vous aurez en débattre je
voudrais pour finir monsieur président a
insisté sur la méthode retenue par le
gouvernement
la concertation qui a dépassé largement
les champs de cet hémicycle
j'ai convoqué une conférence pour le
dialogue social
qui début juillet s'est fixé un
programme ambitieux dont le suivi du
plan de relance
la territorialisation de ce plan qui
sera un de ses axes majeurs et enfin la
démultiplication oui nous avons signé
nous allons signer un accord avec les
régions pour qu'elles rejoignent et
unissent les efforts à ceux de l'état et
avec les autres collectivités locales
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
plan de relance est efficace ambitieux
nous ne doutons pas que vous allez
l'améliorer dans le cadre des débats
parlementaires
il est d'autant plus important monsieur
le président qu'il se déploie rapidement
alors que nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés pour faire face à la crise
sanitaire qui n'est pas terminée tous
les efforts toute la stratégie du
gouvernement est de protéger des
français contre le virus est de faire en
sorte que ce virus entravent le moins
possible la vie économique et sociale de
la nation je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole s'il vous plaît la parole est à
monsieur jean paul dufrègne et à lui
seul
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le président je serais
beaucoup moins long monsieur le ministre
de l'agriculture pour la troisième année
consécutive de nombreux départements
sont durement frappés par un épisode de
sécheresse
mon département de l'allier est
gravement touchée par ce fléau
le déficit hydrique est très important
l'epu les petits ruisseaux sont à sec
les retenues d'eau aussi et la nature
étaient prouvées plusieurs organisations
professionnelles ont saisi la préfète
pour la mise en oeuvre de la procédure
de reconnaissance de calamité agricole
je soutiens cette démarche et notamment
celle consistant à identifier les zones
les plus touchées
la récolte de fourrage au printemps
avaient été normales sans plus ne
permettant pas de reconstituer des
stocks de précaution dans de nombreux
secteurs
l'affouragement auprès des animaux
à commencer en juillet et cette
consommation prématuré de fourrage
destiné à l'hivernage oblige les
agriculteurs à des acquisitions
supplémentaires
monsieur le ministre je suis très
inquiet de cette situation dans un
contexte commercial dégradé pour les
trésoreries des exploitations et la
survie même de certaines d'entre elles
que dire des jeunes agriculteurs
nouvellement installé vous sachant
attachés à la pérennité des systèmes
bovins allaitants extensif et de
l'élevage en général bovins les ovins
sur ces zones souvent des défavorisés
vous groupe andré la gravité d'une
situation qui appelle des réponses
adaptées et rapide
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous me dire
nous dire vos intentions à court terme
pour aider les agriculteurs à passer ce
cap difficile et à moyen terme pour
accompagner l'évolution vers des six des
systèmes plus résistant plus pérenne
tout cela dans un contexte où les
éleveurs sont également souvent souvent
trop souvent mis injustement en cause
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur julien de
normandie ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député jean-paul dufregne
vous avez raison la situation elle est
très préoccupante extrêmement
préoccupante la sécheresse jusqu'à
présent on dit que l est épisodique
elle vient elle est conjoncturelle la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est que la
sécheresse
elle est habituel année après année on
constate une sécheresse qui en 2018
était là en 2019 était là et en 2020 est
à nouveau là et moi je
je partage avec vous un seul objectif
c'est la souveraineté de notre
agriculture l'indépendance de notre
modèle agro alimentaire or la sécheresse
aujourd'hui elle vient percuter cette
souveraineté agroalimentaire et vous
l'avez dit à très juste titre pour les
éleveurs c'est souvent la double peine
non seulement le fourrage n'est pas là
mais en plus il faut aller acheter du
fourrage sur des marchés avec des prix
qui sont extrêmement élevés
et donc il ya deux choses qu'il nous
faut faire pour regagner cette
souveraineté d'abord des mesures à court
terme
vous êtes un spécialiste de la
comptabilité agricole vous l'avais dit
la trésorerie c'est la mère des
batailles et donc on va avec des mesures
techniques déclaré la calamité agricole
là où c'est n'est possible avec le
ministre du budget faire le dégrèvement
sur la tfnb là où c'est possible
également maximiser les avances de la
pac tout ça on va le faire
je m'y engage mais deuxièmement le plan
de relance est un formidable levier pour
s'inscrire dans le temps long ayant au
moins trois choses à faire d'abord être
moins dépendant des intrants comment on
optimise les systèmes d'eau dans le plan
de relance on va financer des
agroéquipements hauteur de 135 millions
d'euros
deuxièmement de faire en sorte qu'il
soit demain plus facile d'avoir des
fourrages avec plus de protéines pour
nourrir de manière plus efficace
nos bêtes dans les élevages et ça on va
le faire aussi dans le cadre du plan de
relance
et enfin troisième élément la protection
on a des solutions techniques prenez les
filets antigrêle ça existe dans notre
pays par exemple et dont on va les
financer
vous savez le plan de relance le premier
ministre vient de le dire c'est de créer
une france plus forte demain
qu'aujourd'hui la france elle ne peut
être forte que si nous avons une
agriculture forte une agriculture forte
c'est une agriculture souveraine nous
partageons le même combat et je le
mènerai à vos côtés et à ceux des
énergies monsieur nenê la parole est à
monsieur paul molac attentif à tous les
territoires le libérer le groupe liberté
et territoires vous interroge monsieur
le premier ministre sur la brittany
ferries cette compagnie créée à roscoff
il ya 48 heures par 48 ans désolé par
des agriculteurs bretons soucieux de
pouvoir exporter leur production dans
les îles britanniques a permis de
développer le transport maritime à
partir de la bretagne et de la normandie
cette entreprise sous pavillon français
c'est assez rare et de tenue encore
aujourd'hui en majorité par des
agriculteurs bretons elle est le premier
pourvoyeur d'emplois en matière de
transport maritime est un fleuron de
l'économie pour autant et selon son
président elle doit faire face à la pire
crise de son histoire
dans un premier temps le confinement un
clouer à quai
la flotte de la compagnie ensuite depuis
le 15 août et la décision unilatérale du
royaume uni d'imposer une quatorzaine à
l'ensemble des personnes se rendant sur
leur territoire depuis notre pays la
relance du trafic a été stoppé net
sept bateaux sur toulouse ne circule pas
les embarcadères de saint malo cherbourg
et le havre sont également à l'arrêt et
des milliers de collaborateurs sont au
chômage partiel
enfin la mise en application au 1er
janvier du bric site avec ou sans accord
laisse planer de nombreuses incertitudes
sur l'avenir
il est de notre responsabilité d'éviter
à tout prix un gâchis économique
le carnet de commandes continue à se
remplir pour 2021
un bateau neuf sera livré en fin d'année
brittany ferries jouit d'un personnel
compétent et d'une flotte en très bon
état de fonctionnement qui se
renouvellent selon les meilleurs
standards écologiques
personne ne comprendrait de voir
disparaître cette compagnie vendredi
dernier à l'invitation des maires du
haut léon communauté une réunion de
crise s'est tenue avec de nombreux élus
dont certains d'ailleurs et sont dans
cet hémicycle est également le président
de la région bretagne loïg
chesnais-girard la volonté des élus
bretons et de la société civile et de
sauver ce fleuron sauf qu'en l'état
actuel de leurs compétences et de leurs
moyens financiers les collectivités
bretonnes n'ont pas les moyens d'agir
avec l'autonomie d'action qu'elle
réclame monsieur le premier ministre dès
lors qu entendez-vous réalisés afin de
sauver la brittany ferries mais comme
les veuves et la parole est à monsieur
le premier ministre
le président mesdames et messieurs et
député monsieur le député molac vous
avez parfaitement raison
la compagnie brittany ferries mais plus
généralement l'ensemble des compagnies
de ferries sont entêtés et continue
d'être très fortement impacté par la
crise sanitaire d'abord par les
conséquences du bras exit double peine
ensuite elles font partie de ces
secteurs d'activité pour lesquels
l'attention du gouvernement est
régulièrement appelé parce qu'ils
constituent encore des domaines où les
outils généraux que nous avons déployés
n'apparaissent vous n'avez pas tort
monsieur le député manifestement pas
suffisant je dois dire que avec vous les
députés du finistère à commencer par
monsieur le président international
madame le faire et tous les autres ont
rappelé l'attention du gouvernement de
manière continue sur ce sujet
je le disais à l'instant cette compagnie
comme les autres mais celle-ci puisque
c'est sur elle que vous m'interrogez a
dit bénéficier des dispositifs de droit
commun des mesures d'activité partielle
tout à fait et un prêt garanti par
l'état à hauteur de 117 millions d'euros
néamoins néanmoins comme vous venez de
l'indiquer dans votre question
cette compagnie et d'autres demeurent en
grave danger
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
l'honneur de vous annoncer aujourd'hui
que le gouvernement a décidé de faire un
effort exceptionnel pour sauvegarder
cette compagne et les autres d'une part
nous avons pour le long terme
saisie avec bruno le maire le ciri pour
prendre des mesures structurelles dont
nous continuons à discuter mais d'ores
et déjà pour passer ce cap extrêmement
difficile
nous avons décidé de rembourser
l'intégralité des cotisations salariales
comme le demandent les professionnels de
brittany ferries pour l'exercice 2001 21
cela représente un engagement de l'ordre
de 15 millions d'euros pour la seule
compagnie brittany ferries et un montant
équivalent nous sommes en train de la
fim et pour les autres compagnies
parallèlement comme je le disais le
travail structurel va continuer avec
l'ensemble des acteurs à commencer par
les dirigeants de ce groupe
nous aurons ainsi permis de dégager
l'horizon
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole à monsieur julien aubert
merci monsieur le président permettez
moi tout d'abord de saluer la mémoire de
bernard debré grand chirurgien débuté
libre ne voit ses détentes
ma question s'adresse à madame le
ministre délégué chargé du logement
madame la ministre je me bats depuis
cinq ans sur le sujet des squats cela
débuter en 2015 avec la sphère maryvonne
cet octogénaire de rennes qui avait été
privé pendant deux ans de sa maison
ça continue aujourd'hui avec la sphère
de théoule sur mer
on ne protège pas le droit de propriété
inscrit pourtant l'un en lettres d'or
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen alors jamais
déposé une proposition de loi qui a été
débattue ici rejeté par la majorité
actuelle et qui vise à créer un délit
pénal d'occupation sans droit ni titre
et à punir le squat de la même manière
qu'on punit aujourd'hui un vol de
scooter
aujourd'hui vous dites que vous voulez
agir
il ne faut pas créer de faux espoirs ma
question est simple
en quoi le dispositif que vous soutenez
permettra de régler définitivement le
problème des squats wargon ministre
chargé du logement
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés
monsieur députés julien aubert nous
avons tous été ému par la situation de
ce retraité à théoule sur mer qui n'a
pas pu avoir accès à sa résidence
secondaire et qui s'est retrouvé bloqué
à l'extérieur avec sa femme face à cette
situation nous avons d'abord voulu agir
avec les services de l'état et ce
retraité a pu finalement rentrer dans
les lieux mais nous avons aussi regardé
avec eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux l'application du droit actuel sur
les procédures qui permettent de faire
respecter le droit de propriété
il apparaît que la procédure
administrative qui s'applique
normalement normalement à la violation
de domicile s'applique difficilement en
cas de résidence secondaire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai souhaité agir
avec le député guillaume kasparian dans
le projet de loi
azap on soutenir un amendement
qui permettra d'améliorer la procédure
de permettre au préfet d'agir de
permettre aux préfets d'être saisis en
48 heures et ensuite donné 24 heures aux
locateurs pour quitter les lieux aux
squatteurs pardo pour quitter les lieux
24 heures aux squatteurs 24 squatteurs
pour quitter les lieux sinon
l'intervention de la force publique
pourra avoir lieu
je souhaite donc que les procédures
puissent être rapide que le droit de
propriété puisse être respecté
la question est moins la codification
des délits que la capacité à agir
rapidement c'est cela que les français
nous demandent
merci monsieur aubert alors écoutez j'ai
bien entendu vos propositions ya des
points où nous pouvons convergeaient
notamment sur la réduction du délai de
réponse du préfet même si vous êtes un
peu optimiste parce que le préfet n'est
pas obligé de faire droit à la demande
des propriétaires légitimes
et n'oubliez pas qu'ensuite il y a un
temps d'application de la décision
donc on seront ils seront pas sortis en
72 heures et ensuite il ya des
divergences
parce que vous restez en réalité dans le
fils du droit actuel qui est de protéger
non pas la propriété mais le domicile ça
n'est pas un sujet de logements c'est un
sujet d'impunité pénale et donc il faut
changer votre philosophique toutes les
atteintes à la propriété doit être punis
y compris la dame qui a acheté son
appartement qui n'a pas encore ménagé ce
n'est pas une résidence principale ce
n'est pas une résidence secondaire
c'est un cadet avait incarné riddick y
compris également ceux qui ont acheté
merci des locataires indélicats
monsieur berre
le chronomètre était déréglé c'est
pourquoi qu'il a pu sembler que monsieur
aubert a vu un passe droit ce qui n'est
pas le cas
madame la ministre il nous reste
quelques secondes je préfère le préciser
juste quelques mots pour répondre à
monsieur le député et dire que ce qui
m'importe c'est la rapidité
l'effectivité du droit c'est à la
procédure que nous travaillons pour que
chacun puisse rentrer dans son domicile
ou dans sa résidence secondaire c'est je
crois ce qui nous a été demandé et c'est
ce à quoi nous répondons merci madame la
ministre la parole et à madame claire
boucher
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres merci chers
collègues je voudrais d'abord dire tout
le plaisir et la fierté que j'ai de 6 g
aujourd'hui pour la première fois dans
cette assemblée
je mesure parfaitement toute la
responsabilité qui est la mienne ayant
accompagné joël giraud mon prédécesseur
pendant près de 20 ans je tiens
d'ailleurs ici à lui rendre hommage pour
son engagement de tous les instants au
service de nos territoires ruraux
notamment montagne à un engagement qu'il
poursuit je le sais au sein du
gouvernement
pour ma part une fois n'est pas coutume
c'est un sujet d'actualité
internationale que je souhaite
interroger le gouvernement
ma question s'adresse donc à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
monsieur le secrétaire d'état plus d'un
mois après la réélection contestée
d'alexandre loukachenko
la mobilisation ne faiblit pas en
biélorussie cette mobilisation est
massive et sans précédent depuis des
décennies d'impression cortège battent
le pavé dans toutes les grandes villes
le peuple clame s'être fait voler son
élection présidentielle depuis le début
du mouvement
des milliers de personnes ont été
arrêtées et les témoignages et
accusations de torture de prisonniers se
multiplient les figures de l'opposition
biélorusse souvent des femmes s'en soit
en exil sont en prison le président
loukachenko au pouvoir depuis 1994
continue de refuser toute concession
exclu tout dialogue avec l'opposition et
se tourner vers la russie pour maintenir
son régime
monsieur le ministre quelles actions
sont à gâcher par la france et ses
partenaires aux prêts européens comme
ceux de l'ouest chez eux pour être
mobilisée aux côtés des centaines de
milliers de biélorusses qui manifestent
pacifiquement pour le respect de leurs
droits de leur liberté et de leur
souveraineté
la france ne peut pas rester
indifférente à cette terrible situation
seulement 200 km du ring
la parole est à monsieur clément bonneau
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
claire boucher je suis très heureux
d'avoir l'honneur de répondre à votre
première question au gouvernement et je
profite ainsi pour saluer celles et ceux
qui rejoignent reviennent dans cet
hémicycle
aujourd'hui la réponse de la france
portée par le clan de la république et
jean yves le drian est une réponse
européenne coordonnée qui tient en trois
types d'actions d'abord un soutien sans
faille dès le premier jour et sans
aucune ambiguïté au peuple biélorusse
qui se mobilisent depuis maintenant plus
d'un mois
ensuite une action de sanctions très
claire et rapide là aussi contre la
répression
et puis l'appui un dialogue politique
national
si je puis revenir rapidement sur ces
quelques éléments je veux dire avant
toute chose y insiste que nous soutenons
cette mobilisation populaire et
politiques en biélorussie depuis le mois
d'août
car chaque week-end désormais des
milliers de personnes risquent leur vie
dans les rues de minsk pour défendre
leur liberté ce sont nos valeurs et nous
nous devons d'être à leurs côtés
mais ce ne sont pas seulement des mots
l'union européenne collectivement à
l'union européenne collectivement a
décidé de soutenir financièrement y
compris les associations de la société
civile et l'opposition biélorusse
je rappelle que plusieurs pays de
l'union européenne accueille des
opposants biélorusses et j'ai eu
l'occasion moi même au nom du
gouvernement de m'entretenir avec
svetlana ticket nobs kaya qui mène
l'opposition pour marquer explicitement
notre soutien bien sûr plus important
encore nous menons une politique de
sanctions coordonnées au niveau européen
là aussi depuis le premier jour la
france le défend ces sanctions sont
décidées elles sont désignés comme l'on
dit elles sont appliquées dans les tout
prochains jours pour cibler les rues les
responsables de cette répression et de
cette oppression et puis et puis valeurs
européennes je dirais et cette pression
que 1000 commettent les européens doit
aussi s'incarner débouchés dans un
dialogue politique national et c'est
pour ça comme vous l'a évoqué que nous
soutenons une médiation de l'eau a eu
c'est autour de ces trois actions que
l'europe unie se mobilisent en soutien
la démocratie en biélorussie
[Applaudissements]
la parole à madame p menti notin un
grand ami des amish un adepte bien connu
du retour à la lampe à huile je veux
parler du président de bouygues telecom
olivier roussat qui a déclaré devant le
sénat
il est erroné d'affirmer que la 5g
permettra des efforts en matière
d'énergie après la première année de
déploiement la consommation énergétique
de tous les opérateurs affichera une
augmentation importante et pourtant et
pourtant loin de toute argumentation
emmanuel macron à fermer le débat avec
arrogance et mépris
comme si le point de vue de la
convention citoyenne qui a demandé un
moratoire sur la 5g n'avait aucune
importance
comme si la notion de progrès était une
fois pour toutes arrimé au consumérisme
et à la sacro sainte compétitivité
mes chers collègues la 5g pose des
questions sérieuses et nombreuses
environnementale d'abord puisque cette
nouvelle technologie est énergivore
toute nouvelle voie créer de nouveaux
flux et toute nouvelle offre créé de
nouveaux besoins alors si on prend au
sérieux la crise climatique
on ne balaie pas d'un revers de la main
cet argument les questions sont aussi
géostratégique puisque face à
l'impossibilité de se doter d'un réseau
autonome français ou européens le choix
demeure seulement entre une offre
étasunienne ou chinoise
c'est enfin un choix d'opportunité alors
que tant de français n'ont accès ni à la
fibre ni à la 4g ni même à la 3g
l'effort doit-il se porter sur l'accès à
un nouveau réseau la haute technologie
pour quelques-uns pendant que d'autres
n'ont accès à rien toujours plus plutôt
que toujours mieux
c'est peut-être un progrès en start up
née shon certainement pas en république
il faut éclairer la décision et échanger
les arguments en niant le débat et en
refusant de nourrir la décision publique
de données scientifiques
vous choisissez la voie autoritaire et
vous plonger dans l'obscurantisme
dans l'ehpad emmanuel macron je vous
pose la question allez vous vous entêtez
à imposer la 5g
allez vous nous obligez la parole est à
monsieur cédric au secrétaire d'état
chargé de la transition numérique des
communications électroniques
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les députés madame la
députée clémentine autain j'avoue que je
suivais votre argumentation jusqu'à la
question scientifique et je pense que
vous avez raison c'est à dire que sur
ces questions technologiques sur ces
questions de progrès nous aurions tous à
gagner à revenir aux faits à une
discussion rationnelle à une mission
scientifique sur cette question sur
défique justement madame les députés ce
que dylan cesse chaque année depuis 2003
dans un rapport rendu public ce que
disent les rapports internationaux qui
sont aux nombres madame les députés de
28000 28000 depuis les années 1950
c'est que jamais jamais il n'a été avéré
que les ondes de radiofréquence ait un
quelconque effet ou un quelconque impact
sanitaire en dessous des modes et des
seuils limites d'exposition
ces seuils limites d'exposition par ozon
puisque nous sommes dans le débat
scientifique
ces seuils des limites d'exposition qui
font l'objet d'un consensus
international entre les experts du sujet
les français en moyenne sont exposés à
des valeurs qui sont 100 fois inférieur
au seuil limite d'exposition et la
france possède en la matière l'un des
cadres de protection les plus exigeants
en la matière et donc madame la députée
je suis totalement à votre disposition
pour que nous ayons un débat sur des
bases scientifiques pour que nous
échangions des arguments scientifiques
mais ce que je ne sais pas faire c'est
lorsqu'on agitent des peurs qu'on essaye
de construire sur un certain nombre de
présupposés et que on se refuse
in fine et avoir un débat rationnel sur
une technologie est là je l'assumé
complètement
dès lors que ce sujet sanitaire dans le
sujet environnemental sur lequel nous
reviendrons si vous le voulez sont
bordés alors oui la france et le
gouvernement assume de se préoccuper de
la question économique parce qu'il ya
une nappe
dit est une absurdité madame les députés
à dire qu'on veut réindustrialiser la
france et à se passer de la 5g
quand les chinois sont 100 millions à
voir la changer et quand 12 pays
européens l'ont déjà commercialisés
merci monsieur milices la parole comme
sur richard ramos
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la justice il y
a urgence à aider voire à réformer la
justice commerciale les entreprises et
par entreprise je parle évidemment des
entrepreneurs et des entrepreneuses mais
aussi des salariés arrive trop souvent
devant nos tribunaux en cas de
difficultés elle y arrive trop tard trop
lentement
il faut les identifier plus tôt afin
d'augmenter les chances de redressement
il est nécessaire que cette période si
particulière dans la vie des entreprises
soit accompagnée humainement et
psychologiquement
nous devons faire en sorte que les
mandataires judiciaires soient davantage
rémunérés sur le redressement d'une
entreprise plutôt que sur leur
liquidation il y à de trop nombreuses
reprises
nos chefs d'entreprise sont considérés
par avance comme des coupables voire des
incapables et donc il n'ose venir devant
les magistrats qui ont galement la tâche
de les accompagner au delà de la
prévention
je pense qu'il faut modifier les textes
sur la procédure de sauvegarde
car elle n'est pas le fruit de
créanciers mais la volonté des
entrepreneurs et ils sont légitimes à
être écoutés trop souvent cette
procédure est vécue de façon violente
est injuste et injuste alors qu'elles
devraient au contraire être la voie d'un
redressement doux et non violents
monsieur le ministre
pourriez vous m'indiquer les mesures que
vous comptez prendre afin de répondre
aux préoccupations des salariés et des
entrepreneurs et comment comptez-vous y
associer les parlementaires
merci monsieur débuté la parole à
monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député ramos comme vient de
le rappeler le président castaner et à
sa suite
monsieur le premier ministre le
gouvernement a fait un effort
considérable en direction des
entreprises en particulier pour autant
nous le savons la crise est là et des
petits entrepreneurs des petits
commerçants
des agriculteurs vont connaître des
difficultés et souvent ils sont
assaillis vous l'avez dit très justement
par la honte la culpabilité et ils
n'osent pas franchir la porte du
tribunal parce qu'ils ont peur en
réalité que cela signe la liquidation
je me suis rendue la semaine dernière et
nous nous sommes rencontrés au tribunal
judiciaire d'orléans et tribunal de
commerce d'orléans qui est ont vu on a
vu que certains petits entrepreneurs
étaient accueillis avec beaucoup
d'humanité qu'ils étaient orientés on a
vu aussi ensemble qu'il existait des
procédures en amont qui ne sont ni connu
ni utiliser et qui permettent très
souvent aux agriculteurs aux
entrepreneurs aux commerçants et
naturellement à leurs salariés de sortir
d'une situation économique très
difficile
ce que je veux faire c'est faire
connaître c'est ces mécanismes qui
permettent en amont d'aller franchir la
porte du tribunal de commerce ou du
tribunal judiciaire s'agissant des
agriculteurs pour être guidé soit qu'il
s'agisse du mandataire ad'hoc soit qu'il
s'agisse du conciliateur
j'ai ordonné une mission flash
réunissons tous les professionnels du
secteur je vais rencontrer tous les
ministres concernés pour améliorer ce
qui est prévention parce que la
prévention permet de sauver un certain
nombre d'entreprises
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député je vous ai je vous
invite monsieur le ministre ait associé
la représentation parlementaire bien
évidemment et nous aurons ici une action
pour surveiller ses mandataires qui
parfois ne sont pas à la hauteur de la
mission qui est la leur
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur philippe gosselin merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture depuis plusieurs mois et
avec une recrudescence ces dernières
semaines nous assistons à une
multiplication de faits de barbaries à
l'eau qu'à l'encontre des kids et des
oreilles ou des queues coupées des
entailles au cutter au couteau chevaux
poneys ne sont malheureusement pas
épargnés c'est ignoble
plus de 150 actes dans 20 départements
sont à dénoncer avec une émotion
légitime un écoeurement de nos
concitoyens pourquoi dans quel but
comment peut-on faire ça à des animaux
au delà de l'effroi du dégoût que cela
nous inspire les propriétaires d'équidés
que ce soit les éleveurs les centres etc
restent en passant par les haras mais
aussi beaucoup de particuliers sont très
inquiets pour leurs animaux mais aussi
pour leurs familles ou leurs salariés
confrontées à des agresseurs
un propriétaire dans l'yonne a même été
blessé à l'armé blanche
face à cette psychose les écuries sont
donc bunkérisé et les rondes sont
établis pour surveiller les animaux
quand il n'est pas possible de les
rentrer la nuit c'est le cas dans la
manche dans mon département en région
normandie mais partout en france
les éleveurs en effet vivre avec le
stress permanent car tout est possible
on l'a vu à la fin du mois d'août
deux femmes rentrer en voiture dans leur
lieu de travail à quimper quand deux
éleveurs armés les ont interceptés
il soupçonnait qu'il les soupçonnait de
faire du repérage
évidemment cette situation ne peut pas
perdurer au delà de la cruauté
inqualifiable en faire les animaux
d'autres drames
vous le savez pourrez suivre survivre
par ailleurs les peines encourues
doivent être à la hauteur de l'atrocité
des agissements le message doit être
clair il vaut du reste dans toutes les
circonstances toute atteinte à des
animaux
doit être répréhensible et sévèrement
punis c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de la
proposition de loi que le groupe l'est
républicain vient de déposer
nous demandons nous souhaitons le
durcissement des sanctions pénales à
l'encontre des actes de cruauté pour les
animaux alors ma question est double et
simple
comptez-vous nous rejoindre pour voter
cette proposition de loi est monsieur le
ministre que comptez vous faire pour
défendre les équidés est défendre les
animaux
merci monsieur débuté la parole à
monsieur julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député la situation elle est
totalement inacceptable
on est aujourd'hui face à des actes
d'une cruauté d'une barbarie
inqualifiable qui plus est on ne connaît
pas les motivations de ceux qui agissent
j'ai rencontré beaucoup d'éleveurs
parfois des éleveurs qui ont été
victimes de ces actes ces sévices nous
étions avec le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin et le président woerth
il y à peu à la rencontre de
propriétaires de chevaux qui eux mêmes
avaient subi de tels crimes et donc la
situation est inacceptable et face à ça
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
d'abord et avant tout mettre tous les
moyens nécessaires pour qu'on puisse
attraper celles et ceux qui commettent
ces actes et que justice soit faite et
justice soit rendue et le président
verts pourraient en témoigner nous
étions avec le ministre de l'intérieur
autour de tous les services enquêteurs
la gendarmerie est pleinement mobilisé
la police est pleinement mobilisée au
moment où je vous parle c'est plus de
150 enquêtes qui ont été ouvertes et je
tiens à saluer leurs actions avec une
énorme détermination des enfants des
personnes de la gendarmerie
le deuxième élément qui nous faut faire
c'est d'accompagner les propriétaires de
chevaux vous l'avez à très juste titre
dit dans votre question il y à une
crainte il y à une angoisse
il ya parfois une peur qui s'est
installée et donc face à ça nous
accompagnons la grande famille du cheval
accompagne toutes celles et ceux qui
possèdent des chevaux
l'institut du des centres équestres par
exemple la fédération française de
l'équitation
toutes ces instituts toutes ces entités
sont mobilisés pour accompagner
on a mis en place des équipes dédiées
pour faire cet accompagnement et je
tiens à le dire à ses propriétaires de
chevaux
nous sommes à leurs côtés puis le
troisième élément c'est la question des
sanctions
il faut le dire il faut le rappeler non
seulement parce que c'est essentiel de
connaître ce à quoi on peut être
confrontés mais également pour éviter
tout acte de mimétisme
si aujourd'hui vous faites de telle taxe
et met en prison euros damende c'est ça
qui venait à pérols
les adieux sylvain templiers ma question
s'adresse à madame le ministre de
l'insertion
madame la ministre l'épidémie de covile
19 et les mesures sanitaires pour y
faire face ont provoqué une récession
très sévère en france et dans le monde
si comme nous l'avons appris hier les
prévisions de croissance de notre pays
sont moins sombres que prévu les
économistes anticipent toutefois une
très forte récession cette année et des
répercussions néfastes sur le front
social et sur l'emploi face à cette
crise la mobilisation du gouvernement et
de la majorité son total pour protéger
de façon durable l'économie l'emploi et
accompagner les familles les plus
fragiles
sur les 100 milliards d'euros prévus
dans le plan de relance présenté par le
premier ministre
15 milliards sont destinés à financer
des mesures pour éviter les
licenciements et soutenir la formation
des salariés
nous le savons madame la ministre la
crise de l'emploi touchera davantage les
jeunes et les personnes les plus
éloignées de l'emploi
si le plan de relance devraient
permettre la création de 160 mille
emplois il est probable que les emplois
créés et bénéficieront principalement
aux personnes sorti depuis peu du marché
du travail
la mobilisation de l'insertion par
l'activité économique iae peut apporter
une réponse spécifique à ceux qui
rencontrent le plus de difficultés
sociales et professionnelles qu'ils
soient chômeurs de longue durée
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux
handicapés ou encore parent isolé
aujourd'hui près de 4000 structures
d'insertion par l'activité économique
sont volontaires pour accompagner en
nombre croissant des salariés éloignés
de l'emploi et je le sais le département
de la haute marne où je suis élue en
compte plusieurs qui obtiennent des
résultats spectaculaires
le président de la république a fixé
l'objectif de 100 mille salariés
supplémentaires dans les structures 10e
d'ici 2022
pour atteindre ce résultat les
structures y est à eux ont besoin de la
mise en oeuvre rapide des mesures du
pacte d'ambition présenté il ya un an
madame la ministre nous saluons le plan
de soutien sans précédent de 300
millions d'euros pour les acteurs de
l'insertion que vous avez mobilisé notre
groupe présentera cet après midi une
proposition de loi et des mesures très
attendues permettant le renforcement de
l'iae par ce texte
nous montrons notre soutien aux
personnes les plus vulnérables pour que
l'accès à l'emploi soit pour elle une
réalité madame la ministre nous avons
plus que jamais besoin des entreprises
intervenant dans le domaine de
l'insertion
en complément du texte législatif
débattu cet après midi et demain quels
autres moyens prépayés prévoyez-vous
d'allouer afin de permettre aux
structures de l'iae de prendre toute
leur part à l'amortissement de la crise
et à la reprise des conneries mais
[Applaudissements]
mais je suis désolé cela ne réagit pas
comme cela devrait vous avez été un peu
long chers collègues mais c'est la
première fois
vous en aviez donc le droit à paroles et
à madame brigitte klinkert ministre
délégué chargé de l'insertion
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés
monsieur le député templiers tout
d'abord permettez moi de vous féliciter
pour votre arrivée sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale
je ne doute pas que nous travaillerons
ensemble dans les temps à venir comme le
laisse à penser votre question au
gouvernement
j'envisage d'ailleurs de me déplacer la
semaine prochaine dans votre département
vous avez évoqué la ppl il ya eu que
nous allons examiner cet après midi le
texte repose sur deux piliers deux
piliers qui sont essentiels et qui sont
deux solutions d'accès à l'emploi avec
deux méthodes différentes
tout d'abord simplifiée simplifier le
secteur de l'insertion pour accélérer le
recrutement des personnes les personnes
les plus éloignées de l'emploi
le deuxième pilier prolongée et étendre
l'expérimentation 00 chômeurs qui a été
co construite avec la majorité
je n'en dis pas plus nous en reparlerons
cet après midi
monsieur le député je suis totalement
d'accord avec vous sur le rôle central
des structures d'insertion
parce que la relance de l'économie passe
par l'insertion de tous
le gouvernement fait d'ailleurs un
effort sans précédent + 120 millions
d'euros qui sont consacrés à l'insertion
par l'activité économique
alors derrière ces sommes vous savez
bien ce sont avant tout des personnes
dont on parle et ses 120 millions
d'euros
eh bien ce sont quinze mille personnes
en insertion de plus par rapport à l'an
dernier
cela va changer la vie de ces personnes
et cela va aussi changer la vie de leur
famille
au-delà de ces questions de moyens la
formation est aussi un outil clé pour ce
qu'ils sont des gages déjà engagées en
parcours d'insertion
enfin je voudrais évoquer en 3 secondes
le dispositif exceptionnel de soutien de
300 millions mise en place par le
gouvernement pour les entreprises
sociales inclusive
merci mme le ministre parole est à
monsieur nov monsieur le premier
ministre nous avons passé ce week end la
barre des dix mille nouveaux cas par
jour qui vont malheureusement induire de
nouvelles hospitalisations dans de
nombreux départements la situation
sanitaire se dégrade rapidement
en gironde les hospitalisations doublé
au chu de bordeaux
en une semaine et ce sont 80 classes qui
ont dû fermer sur l'agglomération
bordelaise tandis que 57 foyers
épidémiques ont été identifiés dont 15
en ehpad
en conséquence la préfète a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures dans le but supposé de
freiner la propagation du virus entre
l'abaissement de la jauge maximale pour
les événements notamment sportifs
passant de 5 mille à mille personnes
l'interdiction des fêtes et brocante
l'interdiction des soirées dansantes la
fermeture des vestiaires des équipements
sportifs ou la limitation des visites
aux pensionnaires des ehpad les
limitations des libertés individuelles
deviennent de plus en plus drastiques
sans que l'on comprenne si ces mesures
sont les plus nécessaires et les plus
efficaces plus gênant encore nos
concitoyens ne comprennent plus la
cohérence entre les annonces
gouvernementales et les mesures décidées
localement entre vos déclarations
monsieur le premier ministre
déclarations rassurantes il ne faut pas
s'affoler le 26 août sur france inter et
la réalité il n'ya plus qu'un grand
écart à faire il y a un an que manifeste
de coordination on pourrait même penser
que le gouvernement se défausse de ses
responsabilités sur les acteurs locaux
face à l'absence d'anticipation pour
cette rentrée qui est malheureusement
dans la droite ligne des internes des
atermoiements et des fautes
gouvernementales au moment de la
première vague
valérie rabault présidente du groupe et
son homologue au sénat patrick kanner
vous en demander de réunir et d'informer
les responsables des partis et
présidents des groupes parlementaires et
d'apporter des réponses précises sur les
intentions du gouvernement pour juguler
ces mères saliver sur le député la
parole à monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
sur le président mesdames et messieurs
député monsieur le député d'un gironde
merci beaucoup pour cette question qui
me donne l'occasion d'évoquer ce sujet
extrêmement sensible et d'actualité
je commence par vous indiquez puisque
vous avez bien voulu relever les propos
radiophonique que j'ai prononcés il ne
faut pas s'affoler
bien sûr qu'il ne faut pas s'affoler
semblez vous étonnez que j'ai pu tenir
de tels propos
l'affolement ne saurait être de mise
quand on est à la manoeuvre à la tête
d'un gouvernement et il ne faut pas non
plus mesdames et messieurs les députés
que l'affolement gagne nos concitoyens
la vigilance la mobilisation et la
responsabilisation très sûrement très
sûrement
je voudrais rappeler quelle est la
cohérence de la politique
gouvernementale sur ce sujet la
cohérence politique gouvernementale elle
est simple elle s'appelle vivre avec le
virus
il y a un virus il y a un virus en
france comme ailleurs il n'est pas
complètement maîtrisé
en france comme ailleurs il y à une
nouvelle vague ou en tout cas une
recrudescence de l'épidémie qui se
présentent
nous devons y faire face avec les moyens
adaptés
c'est ce que nous n'avons cessé de faire
en généralisant le port du masque le
plus possible et je salue et je salue
l'esprit de responsabilité de nos
concitoyens je note bien sûr qu'il y a
toujours des antilles masquer des anti
vaccins qu'on vide ou paco vis de la
france reste la france
mais la politique du gouvernement ne
varie pas je suis très surpris monsieur
le député que vous puissiez dans votre
question reproché au gouvernement de
laisser aux acteurs locaux le soin dada
de d'adopter des mesures adaptées aux
circonstances locales l'état voyez-vous
l'état monsieur le député il a un
représentant dans les départements qui
s'appelle le préfet c'est lui qui est à
la manoeuvre
il concerne les mesures avec les élus
locaux et les professionnels car il ya
dans ces mesures des conditions
d'acceptabilité qui sont essentiels à
l'effectivité de leur mise en place
nous revendiquons cette méthode
d'adaptation est ce que c'est moi qui
depuis paris avait décidé de la
fermeture d'une classe dans le calvados
ou en eure-et-loir loup fixe en nous
fixant madame la présidente
les critères nationaux il y à des
protocoles il y à des protocoles et leur
application et locales il y à une
dégradation à marseille et à bordeaux
des indicateurs sanitaires notamment
notamment et c'est le point le plus
sensible sur les personnes âgées et donc
sur les admissions dans les services de
réanimation et bien nous adoptons et
nous avons raison des mesures plus
sévères l'état d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
forcément un état qui décide tout depuis
paris
l'état efficace c'est un état qui prend
des mesures adaptées aux circonstances
c'est un état qui essaie de concilier de
concilier la vie économique et sociale
et la lutte indispensable contre la
pandémie
j'ai bien l'intention et je vous ai
répondu puisque j'ai reçu de courrier de
la présidente valérie rabault auquel
vous faites allusion
effectivement de faire venir d'inviter
l'ensemble des groupes et des partis
c'était mon intention c'était les
vacances parlementaires nous allons
reprendre ce travail d'explication comme
je le fais à l'endroit de l'ensemble des
françaises et des français
merci monsieur bré ministre paul ta
monsieur jean pierre cubertafon monsieur
le président madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires mes chers
collègues au mois de juillet dans un
entretien avec la presse régionale le
président de la république a rappelé
notre volonté d'engager une nouvelle
phase de la décentralisation la crise
sanitaire a montré qu'une action
publique efficace vient avant tout des
territoires et de leurs les élus du
terrain le moment qui s'ouvre doit donc
nous permettre d'aller vers une
république plus intelligemment
décentralisée dans nos territoires
ce nouvel acte la décentralisation est
souhaitée et attendue pour les maires et
les élus locaux
il doit s'attacher à corriger les
malfaçons de la loi notre faire revenir
de la simplicité et de la proximité dans
notre édifice administratif offrir de
réelles capacités d'initiative aux élus
pour répondre aux préoccupations
quotidiennes de leurs concitoyens
notamment en matière de services publics
de numérique et de mobilité
notre pays vient d'engager un important
effort de 100 milliards pour relancer
notre économie et répondre aux enjeux de
demain
ce volet économique et financier doit
maintenant s'accompagner d'un volet
territorial et administratif qui doit
être l'occasion d'une véritable relance
territoriale s'appuyant sur les nombreux
concertation
réalisée durant ces derniers mois je
pense bien aimé un an à votre travail
madame sur ce projet de loi 3d ou aux
travaux du ségur de la santé qui ont
rappelé la nécessité de mettre les
territoires aux membres pour répondre
aux enjeux de la désertification
médicale
le lien ville hôpital où le soutien aux
ehpad
nous ne devons pas nous contenter d'un
simple jeu de chaises musicales entre
les compétences dévolues aux
collectivités mai mener une réflexion
large sur le fonctionnement de notre
pays à partir des territoires pour faire
du cousu main
madame la ministre pouvez vous présenter
devant nous les ambitions de cette
nouvelle phase de la séance réalisation
et nous apporter des éléments quant au
calendrier scission députés juste parole
de madame jacqueline gourault ministre
de la cohésion de territoire et des
relations avec des collectivités
territoriales monsieur le député jean
pierre cubertafon vous le savez le
monsieur le député les territoires sont
au coeur de l'action du gouvernement et
monsieur le député j'ai le plaisir de
vous dire que cette nouvelle étape de
décentralisation va très bientôt se
concrétiser dans des textes qui vont
être soumis au parlement dès le 2
novembre je présenterai un projet de loi
organique sur les expérimentations
territoriales au sénat en première
lecture ce qui est bien sûr
constitutionnel pour simplifier la
procédure d'entraidé collectivités dans
l'expérimentation et surtout sortir de
l'alternative
je dirais radicale consistant à
généraliser ou abandonner la mesure
d'expérimentation ensuite nous
examinerons au premier semestre de
l'année 2021
un projet de loi ordinaire 3d que vous
connaissez ce projet de loi va
s'articuler autour de quatre axes les
outils de la différenciation
territoriale des mesures de
décentralisation des mesures relatives
au renforcement de l'accompagnement de
l'état déconcentré et bien sûr quatrième
axe la démocratie locale et la
simplification vous le savez depuis des
mois l'ensemble des
lui de terrain de tous niveaux de
collectivités territoriales ont été
associés à cette réflexion ainsi que les
associations d'élus au niveau national
le premier ministre d'ailleurs les
réunira fin septembre à nouveau et
personnellement je retournerai sur le
terrain pour des concertations pour
clôturer et enrichir la loi 3d qui sera
présenté donc en début d'année quant au
plan de relance de modalités de
territorialisation que vous avez
exprimées quant aux la
territorialisation du plan de relance
le premier ministre va dans quelques
jours ce peut-être semaines annoncé
concrètes
la parole est à monsieur le président
eric woerth
monsieur le maire monsieur le premier
ministre mes chers collègues le cd eux
montrent que la france plonge deux fois
plus fort que l'allemagne au premier
semestre
on décroche la palme de la récession la
plus sévère des pays du g7
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la croisée des
chemins et il faudra éviter que le reste
de cette mandature ne devienne pour les
français un chemin de croix pavé de
nouvelles destructions d'emplois
massives jusqu'à présent votre majorité
rester au milieu du gué sur un grand
nombre de réformes ou d'intention de
réformes
aucune nouvelle de la réforme de
retraites une suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui ne s'est pas accompagné
d'une véritable réforme de financement
des collectivités locales et de la
décentralisation et alors que la crise
des gilets jaunes appelé à plus de
décentralisation ont fait aujourd'hui le
chemin inverse avec un plan de relance
ultra centralisé et surtout aucune
réflexion sérieuse n'a été entamée sur
l'avenir de notre modèle social pour
qu'ils deviennent plus juste et plus
durable sans augmentation des impôts
on ne peut pas sans arrêt parler de
réformes et à chaque fois éviter de les
faire
le plan d'urgence c'est bien mais
l'urgence de la réforme c'est mieux
alors le plan de relance de nous
permettre et doit permettre à notre
économie de remonter la pente mais à ce
rythme là on n'obtiendra jamais le
maillot à pois
et si l'on veut devenir le meilleur
grimpeur alors on doit être augmenté
et le potentiel de croissance de la
france la relance et le rattrapage de la
croissance la réforme c'est le
dépassement dans un monde idéal on
aurait une quadrature du car et c'est à
dire quatre plans il ne peut y avoir de
plan d'urgence et de plans de relance
sans un plan de financement de ceux ci
est un programme de réformes
et pourtant ce n'est pas le cas vous
devez donc éclaircir le financement du
plan de relance et des mesures d'urgence
sur les années qui viennent
on ne peut pas s'abriter éternellement
derrière des taux d'intérêt bas ou le
soutien hypothétique de l'union
européenne tout en accumulant les
dépenses et la dette
j'ai conscience que c'est difficile
d'agir face à l'opinion publique il
reste 18 mois avant la présidentielle
vous ne vous ne pouvez pas vous
contenter d'un plan de relance vous qui
planifié tout dites nous quel est le
calendrier des principales réformes
économiques et sociales que vous emmerde
aller sans quoi ce serait un coup d'épée
dans l'eau
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur bruno le maire -ministre
de l'économie de la relance à des
finances merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le président la commission des
finances je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier vous remercier parce que vous
avez voté tous les projets de loi de
finances rectificative que nous avons
proposé avec la majorité
vous remercier parce que vous nous avez
aidés à trouver un accord avec le sénat
sur le troisième projet de loi de
finances rectificative à la fin du mois
de juillet et vous remercier parce que
vous avez annoncé en commission des
finances il ya quelques jours que vous
voteriez le projet de relance de cette
majorité sous l'autorité du premier
ministre et du président de la
république et donc je veux saluer votre
sens des responsabilités et vous inviter
à regarder ce qu'il ya de positif dans
ce que vous avez voté nous venons
d'obtenir les derniers chiffres de la
banque de france
ils montrent que la récession en 2020
grâce aux mesures que vous avez voté et
qui ont été prises par le gouvernement
sera moins forte que prévu elles
montrent qu'en 2021 nous devrions avoir
une croissance forte de l'ordre de 8%
elles montrent que la france est dans la
bonne voie donc je nous incite tous ici
à regarder ce qui se redresse en france
plutôt que de toujours regarder ceux qui
s'effondrent
il y a des motifs d'espoir nous sommes
dans la bonne direction et les 100
milliards d'euros que nous avons mis qui
vont vers l'investissement qui vont vers
les technologies nouvelles qui vont vers
l'hydrogène qui vont vers la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments qui vont vers
la modernisation notre économie qui vont
vers le financement de la 5g qui vont
vers la solidarité pour les plus faibles
qui vont vers le chômage partiel pour
éviter des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois supplémentaires devraient
recueillir l'assentiment le plus général
des représentants du peuple français
merci monsieur woerth du soutien que
vous nous avez apporté et j'espère que
vous ferez écoles dans votre groupe
merci à tous
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à mme adam fait des victimes 9 ma
question s'adresse à monsieur premier
ministre au nom du groupe ps je souhaite
vous alerter sur le projet de loi
relatif à l'accélération la
simplification de l'action publique
le bien nommé pjl asap ce projet de loi
s'il était voté en l'état constituerait
une grave régression sur le plan du
droit et de la démocratie
environnementale
quand ils ne présentent pas un risque
direct pour l'environnement ce texte
réduit en effet considérablement la
place laissée à l'information du public
et au dialogue avec les citoyens
nous ne pouvons admettre au nom d'une
perpétuelle quête de simplification
qu'un texte ne vise exclusivement
l'accélération des procédures
administratives relatives à des projets
dont l'impact potentiel sur la santé la
sécurité ou l'environnement est avérée
nous ne parlons pas ici de simples
lotissement mais bien d'installations
classées de carrière de raffineries ou
de stations service
alors que vient à peine d'être présenté
un plan de relance pour lequel vous
nourrissiez une très légitimes ambitions
environnementales
les français ne peuvent se satisfaire
d'un mode d'emploi qui n'apportera ni
simplicité ni sécurité ni confiance est
au contraire favorisera l'augmentation
des contentieux un an après l'incendié
de lubrizol
nous déplorons que ce texte ne tire les
conclusions de la catastrophe
plutôt que faire le choix et le pari de
l'abolition des règles pourquoi ne pas
faire le choix dans fluidifier les vols
d'exécution en renforçant les moyens
humains et financiers des services
instructeurs par exemple nous ne sommes
pas défavorable à l'industrie ni aux
relocalisations bien au contraire nous
pensons en revanche qu'elles ne doivent
pas se faire au mépris du climat de la
biodiversité et de la santé
environnementale
comment faire d'un côté l'apologie du
zéro artificialisation net en condamnant
de l'autre nos milieux humides pourtant
essentiel à la préversion de la
ressource en eau
comment prôner la simplification du
droit au mépris de son intelligibilité
monsieur le premier ministre vous le
savez préserver la reconquérir la
biodiversité c'est construire la
résidence de notre société de son
économie face à un texte qui prend un
chemin diamétralement opposées nous ne
comprendrions pas qu'une autre que
barbara pompili ministre la transition
écologique
chers collègues la parole et à madame
barbara pompili ministre la transition
écologique
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés cher
frédéric tufnell comme vous j'avais en
tant que député des inquiétudes sur la
loi sur la loi asa parce que justement
comme vous je suis très attaché à ce que
notre droit reste très protecteur de
notre environnement surtout dans une
période où on voit que les
préoccupations environnementales
commence enfin à interagir dans toute la
société
de ce fait mon ministère a été
extrêmement vigilant des premier draft
de la loi jusqu au moment où la loi est
arrivé sur le bureau de votre assemblée
pour faire attention à ce que elle
préserve les fondements de notre droit
environnemental et je pense
fondamentalement qu'on peut faire des
simplifications sans pour autant rogner
sur l'essentiel
pourquoi parce que j'ai constaté aussi
qu'il ya des trous dans la raquette dans
notre droit environnemental
par exemple il y a notamment france
nature environnement qui s'inquiétaient
en disant que si cette loi s'applique et
on pourrait autoriser des fermes de
millevaches
malheureusement on peut déjà les
autoriser aujourd'hui et donc ça veut
dire que nous avons des trous dans la
raquette et ses trous dans la raquette
là il faut qu'on puisse les résorber
pour le reste sur les icpe sur les icpe
les procédures administratives vont être
pour certaines simplifiée mais aucune
n'empêchera qu'il y ait des inspections
jusqu'au bout il y a notamment une
mesure que vous devez avoir repéré qu'il
y ait dans l'article 26 notamment sur la
possibilité pour le préfet après la
consultation du public et sans attendre
la délivrance des autorisations
environnementales d'autoriser le
démarrage de tout ou partie de travaux
en exécution d'un permis de construire
cette mesure est une mesure que j'ai
regardé de près en fait ça ne pourra
exister que si le permis de construire a
été déposé et si il n'y a pas de
problème des espèces d'espèces en danger
et que le public n'ait pas été informés
évidemment
et s'il n'y a pas de problème sur les
autorisations loi sur l'eau et si on ne
peut pas faire de défrichement vous
voyez que vous avez quand même un
certain nombre de précautions qui sont
prises
qui peuvent être mises en danger et
j'attire votre attention par des
amendements mais je suis sûr que vous
serez vigilant merci madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur philippe
maillet merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
l'épidémie de kobe 19 s'intensifient
tant sur le territoire hexagonal qu en
outre-mer c'est le cas à la réunion nous
observons une accélération très
important de la circulation du virus
depuis le 12 août entraînant notre
placement en zone rouge le 5 septembre
dernier avec un taux d'incidence
aujourd'hui qui est de 75 pour cent
mille alors qu'il était de 5 pour cent
mille au début du mois d'août à la
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
avec la reprise du trafic aérien la
suppression de la 14ème stricte en lieux
dédiés votre décret du 10 juillet a mis
en place un nouveau corridor sanitaire
entre l'hexagone et les outre-mer ces
nouvelles dispositions toujours en
vigueur sont l'obligation pour les
voyageurs de présenter le résultat
négatif d'un test pcr réalisés dans les
72 heures avant le vol vers les
territoires ultramarins et un nouveau
test en option sept jours après
l'arrivée
monsieur le premier ministre devant la
montée en puissance de la capacité des
tests que nous saluons il faut également
reconnaître un manque criant
d'anticipation sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne les délais d'obtention d'un
rendez vous puis les résultats se sont
grandement rallonger ces dernières
semaines certains laboratoires en région
parisienne ne garantissent plus la
réception des résultats du test avant
sept jours des cas de fraude récipissé
sont par ailleurs déjà constaté un vrai
parcours du combattant car sans résultat
pas de vol et c'est le début de la
galère
cette situation vécue par des centaines
d'ultra marins ces derniers jours
entraîne des frais supplémentaires non
prévus en hébergement et pour l'achat ou
la modification de nouveaux billets par
familles qui doivent parfois jusqu'à
s'endetter
une attente parfois de plusieurs jours
avec des enfants dans un hall d'aéroport
cette difficulté majeure qui n'est pas
acceptable remet en cause bien sûr la
mise en oeuvre pratique de vote décrit
pourtant nécessaires à la maîtrise de
l'épidémie dans nos territoires
monsieur le premier ministre est il
envisageable que les voyageurs à
destination des outre-mer puissent
bénéficier de délais d'analysé
prioritaire au regard de la règle des 66
eur sur les buts et la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur
monsieur le député je remercie pour
votre votre question d'abord
effectivement faire un point sur la
situation sanitaire sur l'île de la
réunion
on assiste comme dans d'autres endroits
de france à une accélération d'épidémie
depuis quelques semaines ce qui a donné
lieu d'ailleurs une réunion d'urgence
des acteurs localement en date du 11
septembre
faisant le constat que l'incidence avait
augmenté à 75 pour cent mille c'est à
dire au delà du seuil d'alerté
il était même au delà de 100 pour cent
mille chez la population la plus jeune
des 15 45 ans à date il n'y a pas
d'impact sanitaire mesurable et pas de
je dirais de pression notable
hospitalière à très court terme et
croyait d'abord et je préférais
commencer par cet élément de réponse que
tous les services sanitaires dans les
territoires et au niveau national sont
en alerte
s'agissant de la situation de la réunion
comme ça avait été le cas lors de la
première vague épidémique là bas nous
interroger sur la réalisation des tests
dans les 72 heures avant de devoir
partir monsieur le député très
clairement vous connaissez la liste des
personnes qui sont prioritaires pour
accéder au test aujourd'hui ce sont les
personnes qui sont symptomatiques du
coded ce sont les personnes qui sont
qu'à contact de malades avérés ce sont
des gens qui font partie du personnel
soignant ou des aides à domicile qui
peuvent être en contact direct avec des
personnes vulnérables ne pouvons pas
élargir cette laisse de cette liste de
priorité aux personnes amenées à voyager
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord et ça ne
vous a pas échappé il ya des endroits de
notre territoire où les délais d'accès
aux tests même quand on est prioritaire
se sont allongées sous la forte pression
des demandes
compte tenu de l'augmentation d'épidémie
et ce malgré les moyens inédits déployés
sur l'ensemble du territoire pour faire
plus d'un million cent mille tests par
semaine néanmoins à part vous inviter à
ce que un parasite et les personnes qui
doivent voyager a anticipé la
réalisation de leurs prélèvements de
l'ordre d'une semaine il n'y a pas de
solution de priorisation sachez
néanmoins que nous développons et
continueront à développer des
plateformes mobiles destinés aux
personnes qui doivent se faire dépister
dans des délais extrêmement rapides et
que nous mettons tout en oeuvre avec
l'ensemble de la filière de biologie du
pays pour répondre et résoudre ce
problème de l'accessibilité aux tests
merci monsieur mise la parole est à
madame quelques larmes
mon désir merci monsieur président alors
ma question s'adresse sur le même sujet
à monsieur le ministre des solidarités
de la santé monsieur le ministre
bon j'ai bien entendu votre réponse mène
je pense que il y a un problème de
réalité vous disiez tout à l'heure que
il fallait anticiper les tests ce n'est
pas possible puisqu'il faut faire les
tests 72 heures avant donc votre réponse
est vraiment pas compatible à la réalité
notamment aux règles qui sont qui sont
imposé l'obligation de faire le test 72
heures un vent est la condition
indispensable pour que le voyageur
puisse prendre prendre son vol donc je
pense qu'il est important d'entendre et
de comprendre dans quel contexte et dans
quelles conditions que nous nos ultras
marins et y compris d'autres d'autres
nationalités doivent voyager de manière
à faire d'une proposition claire et qui
tienne la route
alors c'est vrai que nous avons de
nombreux compatriotes de nombreux
voyageurs qui sont aujourd'hui dans des
salles d'attentes à orly ou à roissy une
prise en charge effectivement du
transfert du report du voyage est prise
en compte par les compagnies aériennes
mais la prise en charge sanitaire
notamment l'hébergement et quand il
s'agit de famille je suis désolé
monsieur le ministre mais nous vous
demandons d'avoir une réponse adéquate
une réponse appropriée à tout c'est tous
ces voyageurs qui aujourd'hui sont dans
une détresse dans nos aéroports ce c'est
humainement pas possible de poursuivre
dans des conditions pareilles
alors nous attendons une réponse nous
attendons votre réponse et notamment
je vais aussi réagir sur la question des
tests les laboratoires sont engorgés et
je pense que la question d'une politique
publique beaucoup plus
importantes soient prises en compte et
soient mises en place pour que les
laboratoires puisse réaliser les tests
notamment pour les voyages à cuba
je vous remercie monsieur olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités de la
santé madame la députée la réponse que
je vais vous formulez ressemble à s'y
méprendre à la réponse que j'ai
formulées à votre collègue député de de
la réunion d'abord qu'on vous dit
souligne éléphants la puissance publique
ce n'est pas les formations puissance
publique on parle là de milliers de
personnels qui travaillent dans les
laboratoires publics et privés de notre
pays
jour et week-end et qui sont montés en
puissance tout au long de l'été pour
réaliser plus de 160 mille tests par
jour dans l'ensemble de notre pays ce
qui fait que la france est le deuxième
pays qui testent le plus devant tous les
voisins européens qui ont longtemps été
pris comme exemple dans cet hémicycle
je vous demande je vous demande de
reconnaître cet effort s'est pas
l'effort du ministre c'est l'effort de
toute la filière de biologique je me
permets de saluer ensuite madame la
députée vous le savez il y a des
priorités dans l'accès aux tests et le
test a pour objectif principal de
freiner l'épidémie d'empêcher les
contaminations et de permettre à ceux
qui sont positives de le savoir pour se
mettre à l'abri et ne pas contaminer à
leur tour d'autres personnes madame la
députée un déplacement dans les
territoires ultramarins pendant une
longue période assez récentes étaient
corrélées est ce qu'on appelait un motif
impérieux et vous savez que les
déplacements étaient limiter les
déplacements ont été ré autorisé mais
avec une condition et l'ensemble des
parlementaires des territoires ultra
marins se sont mobilisés pour ça que
toutes les précautions sanitaires soient
prises pour ne pas amener du virus là où
il circulait peu et notamment dans
l'étang ultramarins qui sont très
fragile d'où l'obligation de test dans
les 72 heures avant de prendre un avion
un voyage à des placements madame la
députée ça s'anticipe et surtout dans
une situation telle que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui et je ne vais
pas demander à des patients
symptomatiques à des cas contacts ou à
des médecins de devoir laisser leur
place dans les laboratoires de test
complet des gens qui doivent prendre
l'avion puisse le prendre
je ne vous dis pas que la situation est
satisfaisante en tout point de vue
madame la députée
je ne je ne vous dis pas que la
situation est satisfaisante je vous
explique la situation telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui nous priorisons la lutte
contre l'épidémie
la population des personnes avant toute
autre chose merci monsieur le ministre
la parole et à monsieur michel zumkeller
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre nous avons tous conscience que
la crise sanitaire sans précédent que
nous traversons nécessite de mobiliser
tous les moyens visant à lutter contre
la propagation de la commune 19
s'il est évident que nous devons
protéger toutes les personnes non
contaminées par ce virus
n'oublions pas pour autant toutes les
victimes déjà atteintes par cette
infection virale
en effet des malades n'ayant parfois pas
été hospitalisés ou même testé est
considéré comme guéri cherchent
désespérément à se faire entendre à
travers les médias et les réseaux
sociaux
personne n'est en mesure de leur
apporter des réponses sur ces symptômes
qui persistent parfois depuis plus de
six mois et qu'il ne leur permettent pas
de reprendre leur vie d'avant que vides
ils témoignent de grandes fatigues de
gênes respiratoires d'épisodes de
brouillard cérébral avec des difficultés
de concentration de troubles de mémoire
d'apathie d'altération persistante de
l'autorail du goût de douleurs
musculaires et articulaires changeantes
pour ne citer que les manifestations les
plus souvent relayés et confirmés par
des études médicales sérieuse monsieur
le ministre ma question est celle que se
posent tous ceux et toutes celles qui
souffrent actuellement de ces symptômes
post cofide qu'allez vous mettre en
oeuvre pour aider à une meilleure prise
en charge de ces milliers de personnes
qui ne savent plus vers qui se tourner
alors que bien souvent leur médecin
traitant minimise les symptômes et les
renvoie chez eux avec un antidépresseur
et beaucoup de repos comptez vous
généralisez un bilan de santé global
accompagné d'un protocole de prise en
charge afin de les accompagner dans leur
convalescence et peut-être ainsi éviter
que leur état de santé ne dégénère
nécessitant encore plus de soins merci
chers collègues la parole à monsieur
olivier ferrand ministre des solidarités
de la santé merci monsieur le député
pour votre question qui est
complexe et qui appelle une réponse
complexe vous parlez de ces milliers de
personnes on ne sait pas combien ils
sont mais ils sont nombreux en france et
dans le reste du monde qui n'ont pas
forcément une forme grave de coronavirus
en tout cas qu'ils sont généralement
même pas aller à l'hôpital ou en
réanimation
parfois ils sont d'ailleurs jeunes et
qui présente des jours des semaines
parfois des mois après nous n'avons pas
assez de recul pour savoir si c'est
celle aussi pour des années ou pour des
semaines mais la plupart du temps pour
des semaines des symptômes que vous avez
décrit qui sont difficiles à corréler
avec les uns avec les autres tels que
fatigabilité maux de tête parfois des
sensations de détresse respiratoire ou
de gêne respiratoire de gênes cardiaque
que faisons nous nous développons la
recherche la recherche clinique
que nous disent les médecins spécialisés
qui sont organisées dans des unités de
soins spécialisés dédiés également à ce
type de malades il me dit que par
exemple un patient qui se plaint d'avoir
des troubles respiratoires
lorsqu'on lui fait des épreuves
fonctionnelle respiratoire en
pneumologie
lorsqu'on lui fait un scanner low dose
pulmonaire ne présente pas de stigmates
physiques d'atteinte et pour autant il
constate que certains de ses patients
par exemple vont avoir un pou qui va
battre trop rapidement alors qu'ils sont
au repos etc
suggérant qu'il pourrait y avoir ce
qu'on appelle une atteinte type 10
autonomie je pars entre ici dans les
détails de la médecine
tout ça pour vous dire que je suis ça de
près que les scientifiques suivre ça de
près et que pour savoir comment
organiser la réponse sanitaire et mieux
encadrer et développer la recherche
parce que tant qu'on n'a pas de réponse
c'est compliqué de répondre eh bien j'ai
fait une saisine du haut conseil de
santé publique est également une saisine
du conseil scientifique pour leur
demander de m'indiquer les moyens
d'avancer de compiler l'ensemble des
données publiées dans la recherche
internationale et dans la littérature
médicale en france et dans le reste du
monde de manière à d'abord comprendre
comprendre ce à quoi nous faisons face
continuer d'accompagner et ça je peux
vous garantir que les médecins
généralistes les médecins traitants les
pneumologues le font au quotidien les
malades qui sont dans cette demande qui
exprime une gêne persistance après un
peu vide comprendre accompagner avant
demain je l'espère soigner merci
monsieur le ministre à propos les
tableaux ci lui je vous en prie monsieur
le président je comprends la nécessité
de la recherche mais au quotidien c'est
parce que vivent ces gens et je crois
que
on pourrait au moins mettre un passé un
protocole sanitaire qui s'appliquent sur
tout le territoire de la même manière
avec des analyses partout les mêmes je
crois que ce n'est pas incompatible avec
l'idée de mettre de faire avancer la
recherche parce que c'est ça que vivent
les gens ils comprennent très bien que
on n'a pas assez de connaissances mais
il aimerait bien que leur cas soit pris
en compte et surtout de manière uniforme
il ya sûrement des médecins qui font ça
très bien
mais il y en a d'autres qui les renvoie
chez eux avec pas grand chose merci
monsieur le député la porte à madame
sylvie seulement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance les salariés de art à
attendre vos explications
comme vous le savez l'activité de cette
entreprise adaptée subi de plein fouet
les conséquences du redressement
judiciaire de presstalis et daddy qui
liquidation de sa filiale maesa des
auprès de laquelle le hart a assuré en
région pays de la loire la reprise des
invendus de presse contre toute attente
alors que les discussions avec france
messagerie cessionnaire de presstalis
semblait en bonne voie pour conserver un
minima l'activité actuelle de art art
les salariés ont finalement appris que
celle ci devait être transféré à
d'autres structures et ce sans aucune
transparence sur les raisons de ce choix
or cette activité représentait plus d'un
tiers de son chiffre d'affaires sa
suppression remet donc directement en
cause la pérennité de l'entreprise et le
maintien de ses 250 emplois 220
concernant des travailleurs en situation
de handicap
cette décision est incompréhensible et
injuste incompréhensible ans que ses
salariés ont fait depuis plusieurs
années
la preuve de leur efficacité et que e
art as proposé même récemment d'étendre
son mandat injuste car elle impactera
majoritairement des salariés porteurs de
handicap
alors que le marché de l'emploi sera
sinistré par la crise comment le
gouvernement lequel a consenti 120
millions à france messagerie pour son
plan de restructuration
peut-il fermer les yeux sur cette
décision et ce alors que la
problématique du handicap avait été
élevé au rang de priorités de son
quinquennat par le président de la
république ni vous monsieur le ministre
ni madame la ministre de la culture ni
madame la secrétaire d'état chargé des
personnes handicapées n'avait daigné
apporter de réponse à cette situation
critique alors que je vous interpelle
est déjà par courrier en juillet dernier
aussi je vous le demande
l'état at il décidé
et d'abandonner 220 salariés en
situation de handicap compétent efficace
et engagé merci 1 a débuté d'abord le
tas madame agnès venir une heure chez
ministre délégué chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée tellement je vais
d'abord vous dire que nous ne sommes pas
les bras croisés sur cette situation
vous le savez nous avons organisé un
certain nombre de concertation le ciri
regarde très près la situation et nous
sommes bien consciente ces 249 salariés
en situation de handicap doivent être
accompagnés de la manière la plus
précise
je veux rappeler ici les heures qu'on
passait les services du série des
services de la dir et négation
interministériel aux restructurations
des entreprises
le fait que nous sommes en contact avec
la présidente de la région des pays de
loire que j'ai eu au téléphone la
semaine dernière donc je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire qu'il ne se passe rien
et que nous gérons ce dossier dans la
plus parfaite indifférence
il faut aussi regarder la situation de
cette entreprise comme vous le savez le
passif fiscal le passif social est
particulièrement élevé il est d'ailleurs
particulièrement enlevée à l'aune des
efforts que nous avons faits pour
accompagner l'entreprise
je n'ai pas de solution aujourd'hui
immédiate et je le dis bien volontiers
mais sachez que nous sommes en
accompagnement et que nous allons
regarder de très près avec la présidente
de région avec les services de l'état et
avec l'appui
je le souligne du secrétariat d'état à
l'handicap et de la ministre de la
culture qui ne sont pas différentes
parce que je peux pas vous laisser
pointer du doigt un dossier qui est en
grande difficulté pour dire vous ne
faites rien
c'était pas la réalité c'est peut-être
loin des caméras de télévision
mais nous sommes sur le terrain pour
trouver des solutions merci madame la
ministre nous éviter merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre je ne vous
laisserai pas dire non plus que nous
utilisons les caméras simplement les
salariés de retard les 220 salariés dont
je vous parlais qui sont en situation de
handicap vous vous adressez à la
présidente de région
mais ni
dites merci madame la députée la parole
est à monsieur michel larive monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale vous aviez pris
vos précautions monsieur le ministre
vous souhaitiez je vous cite que la
rentrée soit aussi normale que possible
vous aviez raison parce qu'elle s'est
mal passé partout de la maternelle à
l'université
des classes surchargées un nombre
important d'élèves sans affectation sur
tout le territoire national de l'île de
france à villefranche de lauragais des
enfants perdus de vue ne 3900 rien qu'en
seine-saint-denis des étudiants en mal
de parcours sup abandonnés à leur sort
est acquis madame à frédéric vidal
ministre de la recherche propose
seulement qu'ils se responsabilisent
enfin une insuffisance criante d'un site
d'enseignants à tous les échelons de
l'enseignement public
c'est la deuxième rentrée sous qu'ovide
monsieur le ministre cette année vous
aviez de l'expérience et le temps pour
l'organiser convenablement
que se passe-t-il avec notre éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole était monsieur jean michel
blanquer remédie c'est l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés sur le député marie vous avez
été con si je vais l'être
je vous invite d'abord et avant tout à
regarder l'ensemble des pays comparables
à la france et nos grands voisins et
nous pouvons vous pouvez poser la même
question la semaine prochaine regardez
et parlons-en
en effet nous avons fait la rentrée la
plus normale possible dans des
circonstances que chacun reconnaît comme
étant particulièrement compliqué
pourtant tous les enfants de france sont
revenus tous les professeurs de france
sont revenus avec quelques exceptions
ceux qui ne sont pas revenus c'est en
tout cas pas grâce à vous puisque si je
me réfère à ce que disait votre leader
monsieur mélenchon au mois de mai il
conseillait il disait si c'était mon
enfant je ne l'enverrai pas à l'école en
faisant cela ils rendaient pas service
ni à l'école ni aux enfants les plus
défavorisés de france et c'est ça le
problème avec vous c'est que vous avez
des discours sociaux mais des paroles
qui en réalité sont anti sociale alors
la rentrée était le plus normale
possible
oui je le confirme et comme visiblement
vous voulez garder du temps j'en garde
aussi monsieur la rive vous avez à
nouveau je remarque que j'ai voulu être
plutôt apaisant vous ne l'êtes pas
monsieur le ministre tant pis pour vous
j'entends vos arguments quand même
mais comprenez notre inquiétude monsieur
le ministre les enfants qui rentrent à
l'école aujourd'hui sont nos bacheliers
de 2031
ils sont notre avenir l'avenir de notre
pays pourquoi ne pas attribuer des
postes aux enseignants placés sur des
listes complémentaires ils sont
budgétisés ces postes pourquoi ne pas
instaurer la distribution de masques
gratuits du collège à l'université vous
garantir y est ainsi l'application de
votre protocole sanitaire
vous avez raison je regarde l'europe et
l'europe vous dis ceci l'italie va
recruter 84000 personnel enseignant et
je dis bien enseignants rien qu'à madrid
ils seront onze mille à venir renforcer
les écoles et pour garantir des classes
limitée à 20 élèves
alors pourquoi monsieur le ministre
pourquoi vous vous voulez que nous
soyons les mauvais élèves de l'europe
[Musique]
chez ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le député vous ne savez pas de
quoi vous parlez
dans les pays en question je vous invite
dans n'importe quel pays comparables à
la france a recruté 80 4000 personnes
comme étant professeur si vous appelez
professeur les recrutements qui vont
avoir lieu alors nous n'avons pas la
même conception de ce qu'est un
professeur monsieur le député ayons un
débat approfondi sur ces sujets quand
gens n'auront pas à rougir de ce qui
s'est passé
essayer de contribuer à l'unité
nationale autour de l'école plutôt que
d'essayer de faire de vaines polémiques
jamais le taux d'encadrement à
l'enseignement primaire n'a été aussi
favorable dans chaque commune de france
ce taux d'encadrement s'améliore nous
avons mis un million cinq cent mille
heures supplémentaires pour aider les
élèves et aujourd'hui nous sommes
organisés pour les aider vous ce que
vous voulez c'est créer des polémiques
nous ce que nous voulons c'est aider les
élèves de france merci monsieur le
ministre la parole thomas dames justine
bénin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d outre-mer je souhaite tout
d'abord assurer tout mon soutien au
personnel soignant engagés dans la lutte
contre le coc vite 10,9 en france mais
en particulier en guadeloupe où le
service hospitalier sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement sollicités
10 la france les outre-mer et la
gwadeloup vivent une crise sanitaire et
économique sans précédent aujourd'hui
des secteurs majeurs de nos économies
locales sont en crise
et vous connaissez la situation des
collectivités locales en outre mer
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
présenté il ya deux semaines le plan
pour relancer l'économie
100 milliards d'euros pour investir
massivement dans la formation l'emploi
les jeunes l'emploi des jeunes la
transition écologique l'agriculture les
mobilités ou encore le soutien aux
entreprises
alors monsieur le ministre quelle place
prendront les outre-mer dans votre plan
de relance pour vous pouvez vous nous
donner la garantie que nos territoires
bénéficieront d'une action renforcée
pour répondre à l'urgence économique et
sociale dans les outre-mer et
singulièrement guadeloupe la relance d
outre-mer doit se faire avec une méthode
claire territorialisée qui associera
l'ensemble des acteurs aux côtés de
l'état dans un pilotage et une
coordination que je souhaite exemplaire
alors monsieur le ministre quel sera
votre méthode dans les territoires pour
les territoires à partir des besoins
réels des territoires pour déployer ce
plan les hommes et les femmes des
territoires d outre-mer ne souhaite plus
d'un énième plan décidé à des milliers
de kilomètres le contexte social exige
de nous la réussite du plan de relance
en guadeloupe en outre-mer merci madame
la députée la parole est à monsieur
sébastien lecornu ministre d outre mer
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
justine bénin
vous avez raison si le plan de relance
est attendu par l'ensemble de notre pays
il est encore plus attendu dans les
différents territoires d'outre-mer
puisque la crise vient aussi
malheureusement accentuée des
difficultés structurelles que nous
connaissions déjà auparavant
l'adaptation de ce plan de relance il va
se faire territoire par territoire avec
un socle commun vous avez rappelé le
chiffre d'affaires de 5 milliards
d'euros avec notamment des mesures droit
commun qu'ils vont trouver très vite
leurs applications on pense notamment
aux mesures sur l'emploi et la formation
aux mesures également sur l'agriculture
on doit aussi et c'est l'un des premiers
éléments de ma réponse avoir une
adaptation
aux différentes actualités territoire
par territoire
si on parle de la guadeloupe on ne peut
pas faire de la relance sans traiter la
question de l'eau c'est pour cela que
dans le plan de relance 50 millions
d'euros ont été inscrits pour traiter
spécifiquement cette question des
réseaux d'eau pareil pour le plan séisme
antilles qui est un plan qu'on connaît
déjà mais sur lequel on va accélérer l
est encore plus vite avec 50 millions
d'euros supplémentaires deuxième
spécificité pour les outre-mer la
question des collectivités territoriales
vous l'avez vous même soulevé elles sont
souvent maîtres d'ouvragé de la plupart
des projets qui nous intéresse et donc
leur bonne santé conditionne la réussite
de ce plan de relance bonne santé
financière vous avez déjà voté dans le
plan de relance rectificatif dans le
cloud proche de l'autre finances par des
mois rectificatif un certain nombre de
mesures qui permettent justement
d'assurer un filet de sécurité financier
pour ces collectivités notamment avec la
question de l'octroi de mer d'autres
dispositions viendront en renfort
évidemment de décines mais surtout un
renfort d'ingéniérie et on s'est très
très bien et la ministre annick girardin
avait beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet là
beaucoup de projets aujourd'hui n'avance
pas beaucoup de crédit ne sont pas
consommés à cause justement de ce défaut
n'a généré troisième spécificités on
réunira les parlementaires les élus
locaux les partenaires sociaux toutes
les filières économiques sans une
comitologie excessive et inutile mais en
tout cas on a besoin dans chaque
territoire d'associer tout le monde et
on le fera avec vous merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur eric
ciotti
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
à la fin du mois de juin dernier le
magazine le point
révéler un scandale d'état le scandale
qui a fait que pendant six ans dans le
secret le plus absolu le parquet
national financier en dehors de toute
règle procédurale enquêter sur l'ancien
président de la république mais
également enquêté sur plusieurs avocats
dont vous faisiez partie
monsieur le ministre vous qualifier
alors ces méthodes de barbouzes hard en
indiquant que vous alliez déposé plainte
votre prédécesseur a souhaité face à la
gravité des faits qui était en cause et
qui remettent en cause ce principe
d'indépendance de la magistrature auquel
nous devons tous être attaché
votre prédécesseur a mandaté
l'inspection générale de la justice pour
conduire une enquête pour rechercher les
failles les fautes qui avait conduit à
ce que pendant cette durée de six ans
cette procédure puisse se dérouler sans
qu'aucun magistrat du siège qui par
ailleurs été saisi d'une affaire sur
nicolas sarkozy en soient informés ce
qui aurait permis de disculper
totalement nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui
vous avez reçu des mains de l'inspection
générale de la justice ce rapport vous
l'avez rendu public ce rapport formule
des préconisations
il parle de défauts de gouvernance à
revoir
il propose des solutions pour faire en
sorte que plus jamais cette situation ne
se produise
alors face à la gravité des faits que
vous avez je le redis vous même
légitimement dénoncer quand bardefou
faire monsieur le ministre que pour que
plus jamais une affaire de cette nature
ne remette en cause les institutions de
la république
merci monsieur le député la parole la
parole est un monsieur le garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice le
président mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député ciotti tout le monde
se souvient de l'émoi suscité par cette
affaire
en france on prête ou le concitoyen et
dans le monde judiciaire en particulier
j'ai dit ce que vous avez rappelé
j'étais alors avocat
c'est ma prédécesseure qui a vous l'avez
rappelé saisi l'inspection générale de
la justice le rapport a été remis ce
matin j'avais dit que je le rendrai
public ce que j'ai fait on peut y lire
dans ce rapport un certain nombre de
choses très intéressantes
le défaut de gouvernance que vous avez
rappelé mais aussi un suivi interne
distendu qu'en des termes choisis ces
choses-là sont dites n'est ce pas un
manque de rigueur dans le traitement de
la procédure une remontée de
l'information lacunaire bref peut-être
un certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
je note également que deux magistrate du
parquet national financiers l'une à la
retraite l'autre en activité n'ont pas
déféré aux convocations de l'inspection
et ont refusé de répondre aux questions
ces raisons m'ont amenée dès ce matin à
saisir la direction des services
judiciaires qui procède en ce moment
encore aux analyses nécessaires analyse
minutieuse dont j'aurai les résultats
prochainement
j'assure devant la représentation
nationale que si des manquements sont
susceptibles d'être qualifié de faute
disciplinaire je n'hésiterai pas à
saisir les instances compétentes en
l'occurrence l'inspection générale de la
justice en enquête administrative
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
merci monsieur le ministre la parole de
ramla dit ali merci monsieur le
président mais c'est le ministre d
outre-mer mes chers collègues mayotte
connaît actuellement une flambée de
violence sans précédent
un effet de publier - le territoire
connaît de très vives tensions
matérialisée par des actes de violences
physiques et sociales qui se multiplient
quotidiennement accentuée par une grave
crise socio économique
le constat est sévère et génère une très
forte inquiétude au sein de la
population
pas un jour sans que l'on assiste au
triste spectacle de voitures dégradées
brûlés de la quête automobilistes
motards de pillage affrontements de
bandes rivales
cette délinquance des jeunes devient de
plus en plus violente
certains sont mêmes armés de machettes
et sèment le chaos de plus la colère des
habitants contre les immigrés
clandestins s'exacerbent
en conséquence mayotte se trouve dans
une situation de pourrissement avec des
habitants apeurés exaspérés qu'ils
décident de se protéger eux mêmes une
entrée scolaire mouvementée et une
économie qui se fragilise davantage pass
1 jour
en effet sans grève social touchant tous
les secteurs d'activité je pense tout
particulièrement aux employés du
supermarché jumbo score dans le
mouvement dure depuis plus de 60 jours
et dans deux jours l'intersyndicale de
mayotte sera en grève pour une durée qui
risque d'être indéterminée pour pallier
à ces tensions des propositions ont été
faites par les élus celle notamment de
recourir aux militaires et déployer un
plan à dix à mayotte à l'instar de
l'opération harpie en guyane contre
l'orpaillage clandestin et qui
d'ailleurs avait été évoquée par le
président emmanuel macron lors de la
rencontre avec les maires d'outre-mer à
l'elysée en février 2019
dans le cadre du grand débat national la
direction territoriale de la police
nationale nouveaux services déconcentrés
de l'état à mayotte ne demande qu'à voir
ses équipes renforcées
force est de constater qu'en dépit des
efforts de l'état
la saynète de lutte contre l'insécurité
mise en place est insuffisant au regard
de la situation incendiaires que connaît
mayotte le désespoir et le sentiment
d'abandon sont très forts au sein de la
population mahoraise
elle est excédée par cette insuffisance
de réaction face à cette violence
enfants les marées sont des français
qui attendent des résultats concrets et
des mesures adéquates afin de rétablir
la loi et l'ordre sous le télépathe
mahorais mais c'est le ministre simard
député la parole de monsieur sébastien
lecornu ministre d outre mer merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés madame la député ali il faut
se parler très franchement la situation
à mayotte est extrêmement préoccupante
et malheureusement la situation ne date
pas d'hier
sur ces défis qui nous attendent je
pense aussi même la députée qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à dresser des solutions en
regardant les choses et on en parlant
sans tabou
la première des choses c'est bien
évidemment la question de la montée en
puissance régalienne cette affaire
évidemment suivi avec le ministre de
l'intérieur rappelle un chiffre
pratiquement plus de 1200 militaires de
la gendarmerie et policiers nationaux
sont désormais positionné à mayotte soit
pratiquement plus de 400 effectifs
supplémentaires depuis 2015 avec un
stand de renforts également de
l'autorité judiciaire
le deuxième défi que nous devons relever
là aussi sans tabou c'est évidemment la
question de l'immigration clandestine et
on le sait très bien
le plan chic andra qui a produit des
résultats tout à fait significatif en
2019 a malheureusement été gêné par le
confinement et la crise qu vide ce plan
chic andra ce dispositif chic andrade
doit de nouveau remonter en puissance et
produire ses effets en lien notamment
avec les forces armées qui sont déployés
dans le cadre de l'action d'état en mer
notamment la marine nationale
mais madame la députée vous le savez
aussi il nous faut parler vrai avec les
comores avec une initiative diplomatique
forte désormais pour avoir aussi des
résultats en la matière en matière de
lutte contre l'immigration et puis
troisième chose même les députés mais
vous le savez puisque je voulais indiqué
à l'ensemble des parlementaires des élus
départementaux et dans cette réunion
très républicaine que nous avons tenus
il ya maintenant 15 jours nous
approchons des 10 ans de la
départementalisation de mayotte
nous devons dresser sereinement
calmement tranquillement un premier
bilan de cette départementalisation
notamment dans le cadre des compétences
qui ont été transférées aux
collectivités territoriales la sécurité
c'est aussi l'aide sociale à l'enfance
c'est aussi la protection matin
infantile autant de sujets qu'il nous
faut relever tous ensemble merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur alain bruneel
merci monsieur prêt dans ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie et
des finances general electric qui en
prend encore treize mille salariés en
france a annoncé la semaine dernière la
suppression de 750 trois postes ces
suppressions d'emplois concernerait la
branche hydro qui fournit des turbines
pour les barrages hydroélectriques et
surtout la filière réseau énergies
renouvelables le site de villeurbanne
pourrait fermer des sites de st priés de
grenoble et de belfort sont menacés dans
l'hydroélectricité le site de grenoble
est déjà subi une sévère restructuration
en 2018
l'an dernier general electric avait
prévu la suppression de 800 postes dans
l'entité turbines à gaz de belfort pour
en supprimer finalement 500 dans le
cadre d'un accord un accord que la
direction de general electric piétine
aujourd'hui sans vergogne allons-nous
encore accepter longtemps
le dépeçage de la france de la branche
énergie dalton cédés à general electric
en 2014 dans des conditions plus que
discutable sous la houlette de l'actuel
chef de l'état ne pouvons pas tolérer de
voir disparaître fleuron industriel de
voir des activités délocalisées
avec à la clé la disparation des savoir
faire incomparable à l'heure où il est
question de reconquête de notre
souveraineté industrielle et d'investir
dans la transition écologique
nous devons mettre un terme à ce
scandale l'an dernier déjà nous avions
invité dans une proposition de
résolution signée par les députés de
différents groupes à faire une offre
politique d'achat dalton nous estimons
aujourd'hui plus que jamais qu'il n'y a
pas d'autres solutions pour sauver
l'emploi et ce maillon essentiel de la
transition écologique que de
nationaliser les activités d'al comme
monsieur le ministre
y êtes vous prêts
merci monsieur le député la parole à
madame agnès pannier rue nash et
ministre délégué à l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
brunel vous m'interrogez sur les
intentions de guy s'agissant des
divisions en europe dans le domaine de
l'hydroélectricité et des réseaux et
énergies renouvelables vous le savez
bruno le maire et moi même et elisabeth
bornes qui est maintenant doté
d'instruments importants pour
accompagner tous les enjeux de
restructuration d'emploi suivons de très
près cette situation et je veux
remercier les élus du territoire qui se
mobilise également des territoires sur
lesquels intervient alstom je pense
notamment à christophe grudler qui m'a
encore interrogé récemment sur cette
situation
député européen est très attaché à son
territoire
j'ai eu c'est une implantation
historique elle emploie nos meilleurs
ouvriers elle utilise nos meilleurs
savoir-faire alors soyons clairs certes
nous traversons une crise économique
certes des carnets de commandes se
vident et dans certains certaines
activités ses massifs mais nous
n'accepterons pas de plan social
opportuniste et c'est ce que bruno le
maire a très clairement dit s'agissant
de cette situation et d'autres
situations
nous venons d'annoncer un plan massif
d'accompagnement de l'économie un plan
inédit de 100 milliards d'euros ce plan
il nous donne des outils pour aider les
entreprises a rebondi hier et protéger
les compétences car c'est long jeu que
porte notamment elisabeth bornes avec
l'activité partielle de longue durée
avec l'accompagnement et le
développement de nouvelles activités
industrielles que je porte
ji a prévu d'embaucher 300 emplois à
cherbourg et saint nazaire dans l'éolien
offshore
réjouissons nous et nous devons
probablement pouvoir faire des choses
dans l'hydrogène vous savez que nous
l'accompagnons ce secteur à hauteur de 7
milliards d'euros
alors oui nous allons mener un dialogue
exigeant avec j pour que l'entreprise se
saisissent de nos dispositifs et porte
un projet ambitieux pour l'industrie
française
c'est en ce sens que nous venons
d'écrire il ya quelques jours à la
récolte qui est le président-directeur
général dj avec bruno le maire vous
pouvez compter sur nous pour défendre
les intérêts de l'industrie française
merci mais la parole de monsieur pierre
yves bournazel
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur paris a fait face à une
nouvelle vague de violences ce week-end
en marge d'une manifestation des gilet
jaune
aucune revendication si respectable soit
elle ne peut légitimer cette violence
les groupes de casseurs qui se greffe à
ces manifestations n'ont pour seul but
que le chaos
monsieur le ministre comment comptez
vous agir face à ces casseurs que les
parisiens ne supporte plus par ailleurs
d'autres problèmes lourd pèse notamment
dans les quartiers du nord-est de paris
dans le 18e arrondissement par exemple à
barbès à la goutte d'or à château rouge
à la porte de montmartre à l'apport de
petits en cours à la chapelle le cadre
de vicier largement dégradée dans le 19e
arrondissement cette semaine des bandes
en sont venus à tirer au mortier dans le
quartier rébeval belleville en plein
jour à cela s'ajoutent les trafics
traditionnel drogue proxénétisme vente
illégale qui continue de faire des
ravages dans tout le nord-est de paris
sans parler du bruit et de nombreuses
incivilités du quotidien que les
parisiens ne supporte plus la situation
n'est malheureusement pas nouvelle elle
est le résultat de plusieurs années pour
ces citoyens se posent la question de
l'impuissance publique il y à une
saturation de la violence et des
incivilités la république se doit de
leur apporter des solutions des réponses
très concrètes pour regagner leur
confiance
nous croyons à l'égalité de tous les
citoyens sans aucune distinction
d'origine de quartier ou d'âge
nous croyons la sécurité pour tous
j'avais fait la proposition il ya plus
d'un an d'un dispositif de travaux
d'intérêt général
tu casses tueur et par tu salis tu
nettoies je suis satisfait d'entendre le
gouvernement agir en ce sens une police
municipale est également attendu par nos
concitoyens à paris tous les acteurs y
sont prêts et constructif
la ville de paris également alors
monsieur le ministre
peut-on avancer sur cette question de la
police municipale nous connaissons votre
détermination monsieur le ministre
nous connaissons votre énergie alors
quelles actions comptez vous mettre en
oeuvre afin de permettre un retour à la
tranquillité à la sécurité où elles sont
tant attendu merci beaucoup merci la
part de monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
président monsieur le député monsieur
député pierre-yves bournazel
vous avez posé plusieurs questions mais
qui ont tous comme point d'alliance la
sécurité à paris d'abord sur le match de
l'ordre je constate effectivement que
s'il ya pu y avoir des violences en
marge des manifestations des gilet jaune
celle-ci à part de véhicules bleus
brûlée et quelques feux de poubelles
c'est quand même tenue dans des
conditions je crois qu'ils ont changé
notamment parce que le schéma du match
alors de nouveau que mon prédécesseur
christophe castaner et moi même avons
mis en place permet je crois la
meilleure organisation de ces
manifestations dont certaines vous le
savez sont de plus en plus violente
mais tout le mérite en revient bien sûr
à nos forces de l'ordre deuxièmement
j'ai constaté comme vous les très
nombreux faits ce règlement de comptes
c'est vrai pour paris mais c'est vrai
aussi pour la petite couronne parisienne
et des difficultés forte d'ordre public
que nous connaissons à paris qui sont
tous liés au trafic de stupéfiants et
lutter contre le trafic de stupéfiants
ces luttes et évidemment pour imposer la
sécurité publique l'ordre public la fin
des cambriolages la fin des agressions
parce qu'évidemment il ya un lien entre
l'insécurité publique et les trafics de
stupéfiants qui gangrène nos quartiers
singulièrement le nord de paris et le
département de la seine saint denis des
hauts de seine et du val de marne
troisièmement vous me posez la question
de la police municipale dans la
proposition de loi de vos collègues
fauvergue et tour au il y aura lorsque
sera mis en discussion et je souhaite
personnellement avec le premier ministre
et sous son autorité que ce soit le plus
rapidement possible la proposition faite
par léman par les parlementaires
parisien je pense à monsieur rivaux mais
à l'ensemble des parlementaires parisien
de la majorité d'adopter en tout cas ce
sera un avis favorable du gouvernement
les dispositions pour la création d'une
police municipale à paris l'accord a été
donné également par la maire de paris
que j'étais rendre visite au lendemain
de ma nomination je crois que sur ce
point très républicain on peut trouver
une grande évolution qui sera au bon
point de la majorité d'autant qu'elle
pourra soulever
cette police municipale un certain
nombre de sujets qu'on n'aura plus à
traiter la police nationale et qui
pourra se concentrer sur la délinquance
de droit commun et sur les trafics de
stupéfiants
merci puni par holt à monsieur arnaud
viala merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre dès son
premier jour la crise sanitaire a
engendré des perturbations considérables
des services postaux de notre pays
jusqu'à suscité un fort mécontentement
des français quant à la distribution du
courrier et des colis de la presse après
plusieurs mois en ville comme à la
campagne le compte n'y est toujours pas
ni sur l'ouverture des bureaux de poste
erratique clairsemé irrégulière limitée
souvent à quelques demi-journées par
semaine et quelques heures par jour en
parfait décalage avec les besoins des
clients ni sur la distribution du
courrier et des colis longtemps limité à
deux ou trois jours par semaine sur les
six qu'exige le contrat passé par
l'entreprise la poste avec l'état et
encore aujourd'hui quand on est à cinq
jours par semaine à l'exclusion du
samedi
ma question ne vise pas les personnels
de la poste qui ont tout mis en oeuvre
pour apporter un service adapté à leurs
clients tout au long de la crise souvent
avec l'angoissé de leur propre sécurité
souvent sans consignes claires ni
équipement adéquat beaucoup confie
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui ne pas comprendre
la stratégie de repli de leur entreprise
comment est il tolérable que la
direction de cette grande entreprise
nationale
certes privés mais sous contrat avec
l'état puisse aussi longtemps resté
aussi ostensiblement un marge de
l'effort de relance de notre pays
cette posture fragilise notre économie
et fragilise également la poste et son
maillage territorial sur le long terme
en favorisant de fait la montée en
puissance de concurrents complètement
privé eux qui ont compris que la demande
doit être satisfaite
monsieur le premier ministre que comptez
vous faire pour que la poste respecte
ses engagements vis-à-vis de l'état et
surtout vis-à-vis des français
je vous remercie merci la parole à
monsieur alain griset ministre délégué
chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés monsieur le député viala la
crise sanitaire fortement touché les
services postaux au même titre que
toutes les activités économiques et les
services publics
nous avons été très attentifs à ce que
la poste continue à assurer dans les
meilleures conditions les services
essentiels à la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens tout haut protégeant la
santé de ses salariés et de ses usagers
je tiens à rappeler que du 16 mars au 10
mai ce sont près de 8 salariés sur 10
qui étaient présents pour assurer
l'activité postale ce titre permettez
moi de saluer l'engagement et la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des
personnels de la poste qui ont été en
première ligne de cette crise sanitaire
depuis le 11 mai
la presque totalité des bureaux de poste
a progressivement rouvert avec des
horaires adaptés la distribution
quotidienne de la presse des colis des
lettres à retrouver un rythme normal et
le groupe la poste a même mis en place
durant le mois de juillet des points de
service saisonnier pour assurer une plus
grande couverture territoriale
vous avez monsieur le député vous mêmes
étaient présents à la réunion
d'implantation d'un point saisonniers
dans la commune de couvertoirade vous
nous avons la volonté de faire que la
poste puisse continuer d'assurer un
service de proximité au quotidien
même en temps de crise ça c'est que nous
continuons de surveiller de très près
les mesures prises en oeuvre par la
poste pour assurer un service postal
complet afin d'accompagner dans les
meilleures conditions la reprise de
l'activité de notre pays
merci monsieur de débuter monsieur le
ministre je ne conteste pas du tout
votre volonté de faire en sorte que le
service retourne à la normale mais je
vous assure que ça n'est absolument pas
le cas à l'heure actuelle j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'en plaindre auprès de
monsieur le président directeur général
de la poste par écrit dans l'été auprès
de ses responsables régionaux et locaux
que j'ai rencontré cette semaine et qui
convienne du fait qu'ils ne sont pas
revenues à la normale
et deuxièmement il ya un gros problème
d'information des élus est également des
clients de la poste puisqu'il s'agit de
clients dorénavant qui n'ont jamais eu
aucune communication directe sur les
évolutions du service mais en l'espèce
et sa remontée en bus et la parole à
madame françoise bas les bleus merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mes chers collègues nouvellement député
de la première circonscription de la
vienne et même si mon territoire ne
borde pas nos mères ni nos océans
je me sens concernée par la crise que
traversent nos compagnies maritimes
car l'enjeu de ces compagnies et
national j'associe sandrine lefebvre
député du finistère où siège la
compagnie brittany ferries ainsi que
l'ensemble des députés bretons et
normands à ma question monsieur le
premier ministre la brittany ferries
malgré des efforts structurels en
interne subit aujourd'hui de plein fouet
les conséquences du bric site de la
crise sanitaire et des récentes mesures
de 14 n mise en place par le royaume uni
pour les voyageurs arrivant de france
même si la compagnie bénéficie des
mesures de chômage partiel d'un prêt
garanti de l'état à hauteur de 117
millions d'euros remboursable sur 5 ans
cela n'est pas suffisant et plus de 3000
emplois se trouvent aujourd'hui menacé
nous députés de la majorité nous
souhaitons soutenir les emplois maritime
il nous faut donc à tout prix éviter le
plan social
de nombreux élus locaux se sont réunis
ces derniers jours comme vendredi
dernier à saint pol de léon dans le
finistère soucieux de l'avenir de ce
fleuron de l'économie locale et
nationale
pourtant la situation ne semble pas
évoluer
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
est donc la suivante quelles sont les
mesures que le gouvernement souhaite
mettre en place pour les accompagner
merci merci la parole de taman amman
jordan lice de la maire monsieur le
président madame la députée françoise
bayle et bleu tout d'abord vous
féliciter d'être effectivement
aujourd'hui installé dans vos nouvelles
fonctions
vous l'avez dit nous vivons un moment
d'incertitude incertitudes face à la
crise cotco vida certitudes face aux
briques site dans les régions dont vous
avez parlé la bretagne la normandie et
les outrances alors oui il est important
que nous puissions être présent et nous
l'avons été aux côtés des opérateurs
comme brittany ferries ou des fds dans
vos régions sur sur trois périodes
le premier ministre a réaffirmé
l'engagement du gouvernement de tout le
gouvernement et des décisions qui ont
été prises d'abord en urgence bien
entendu vous les avez cité premier
ministre aussi je vais pas les rappeler
ensuite à moyen terme
ou plutôt à court terme et c'est une
décision que le premier ministre vient
de prendre une mesure exceptionnelle que
nous avons le plaisir de vous annoncer
aujourd'hui pour toutes les entreprises
de ferry de transport de passagers c'est
à dire l'effacement des charges sociales
pour 2021
elisabeth bornes qui vient de également
nous dire qu'elle proposait l'activité
partielle de longue durée qui est une
autre mesure un autre outil qui peut
être utilisé à court terme mais il ya
aussi le long terme
et ça c'est important et c'est aussi le
rôle de la ministre de la mer c'est de
dire de cette crise faisant une
opportunité comme le président de la
république nous l'a dit transforme en
transformant effectivement ce secteur
d'activité travaillant sur des réformes
structurelles à travers effectivement un
pavillon en france qu'ils soient plus
attractifs et je vous invite j'invite
effectivement la représentation
parlementaire
parce que je le mène ce travail avec
l'armateur de france avec l'ensemble des
élus des territoires et nous allons
pouvoir proposer à ses hommes à ces
femmes à ces milliers d'hommes et de
femmes que ça concerne dans les trois
régions que j'ai cités comme dans la
méditerranée pour avoir un avenir plus
sûr pour eux et pour leurs familles plus
juste plus équitable et surtout avoir
des entreprises plus attractive
française la france deuxième domaine
maritime ne peut pas voir des pertes
dans sa flotte ne peut pas avoir moins
de marins demain
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame bénédicte de taurine sûr merci
monsieur le premier ministre
se laver les mains est une règle de base
pour lutter contre le coronavirus les
comment peut-on faire quand on n'accède
pas à l'eau en guadeloupe et en
martinique on constate des interruptions
récurrentes dans la fourniture de l'eau
potable à des dizaines de milliers
d'habitants en guyane ce sont les
quartiers défavorisés de cayenne qui
sont sans eau et sans électricité
début septembre une semaine après le
retour en classe la plupart des écoles
de la région de grande terre sont restés
portes closes
le secrétaire départemental du snes fsu
a indiqué que ce sont surtout les
coupures d'eau qui force à fermer les
établissements
à mayotte le manque d'accès à l'eau
concernerait quatre habitants sur dix la
moitié de la population de ce
département français ne disposerait pas
de raccordement au réseau d'eau potable
pour y remédier le préfet de mayotte a
décrété le rationnement en nous pour la
directrice de la rs à mayotte dominique
voynet la mesure de coupure d'eau vise à
mieux anticiper et éviter les
affrontements civile entre communautés
entre villages et convaincre que les
mains en or et qu'on n'est pas passif
mais acteurs du développement
dire qu'on est acteur du développement
en coupant l'eau aux populations laisse
sans voix
l'anticipation aurait été de mettre en
oeuvre les investissements nécessaires
qui permettent d'améliorer le réseau par
exemple
en effet la situation n'est pas nouvelle
mayotte a déjà connu une grave crise
d'approvisionnement en eau et à cause
d'une sécheresse exceptionnelle le plan
urgence au premier en 2017 a été
largement insuffisant et ce sont
toujours les plus fragiles qui pâtissent
de votre manque de volonté politique
que ce soit dans les outre mer ou
ailleurs et tout particulièrement à
mayotte
de l'argent il y en a vous l'avez assez
démontré ces derniers mois en
distribuant des milliards aujourd'hui
l'urgence est de satisfaire les besoins
élémentaires de la population y compris
dans les outre mer il est inacceptable
que des personnes soient privés d'eau
potable
monsieur le ministre comment comptez
vous faire
chacune et chacun accède à ce bien
essentiel qu'est l'eau quel que soit son
lieu de vie sur le territoire
merci la parole à monsieur sébastien
lecornu ministre d outre mer merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés madame la députée s'il ya
bien un dossier sur lequel il ya de la
volonté politique de ce gouvernement
c'est bien d'avancer sur la question de
l'eau potable
mais madame la députée c'est une
compétence et je vais commencer par là
qui est décentralisée depuis maintenant
plus de 40 ans ça veut dire que ce sont
les collectivités territoriales qui sont
compétentes
est ce que cela nous empêche d'avancer
et d'agir la réponse est non et nous le
faisons
2 je ne voudrais pas que dans votre
question vous laissiez à penser que les
tours d'eau comme on dit si bien il
existe malheureusement guadeloupe depuis
longtemps il hésite depuis peu à mayotte
sont une solution ce n'est qu'une
solution temporaire transitoire en
attendant de réaliser les
infrastructures 3 mais ne cherchons pas
à s'opposer sur ce sujet nous sommes
d'accord donc sauva sauf à faire de la
récupération politique politicienne
ce qui évidemment serait détestable pour
tous nos concitoyens d'outre-mer qui
vivent très difficilement cette
situation en guadeloupe à même la
députée
aujourd'hui on produit trois fois plus
d'eau potable que de nécessaire et
inversement
on perd 65 % d'eau en fuite d'eau dans
les réseaux en guadeloupe ça veut dire
qu un défaut d'investissement majeur ces
dernières années
maintenant faut faire du rattrapage en
faire du rattrapage déjà il faut avoir
malheureusement une réponse en
ingénierie et en gouvernance de l'eau
vous savez très bien que on a ce concept
que lopez l'eau sauf que moins à d'eau
potable mois on arrive à faire facturer
l'eau - facture l'eau plus on a des
services qui sont déficitaires donc il
faut arriver à rompre ce cercle vicieux
ça c'est très important et c'est très
urgent c'est notamment urgent en
guadeloupe de l'argent est mis sur la
table en matière véritablement
d'accompagnement des collectivités c'est
le plan odom que vous connaissez bien
parce que on en a parlé suffisamment ici
dans cet hémicycle dans le plan de
relance on remobilise 50 millions
d'euros supplémentaires uniquement pour
les réseaux d'eau potable et aussi
parfois d'assainissement parce que les
deux peuvent être liés l'enjeu
maintenant c'est un art d'exécution avec
les différentes entités locales avec les
syndicats avec les collectivités
territoriales ou alors soyons plus
directe et demandé la recentralisation
de la compétence eau mais au moins dans
un débat clair
la séance des questions au gouvernement
et terminer la séance est suspendue